READ SOME DIRECTIONS FIRST. SO
THESE ARE THE REC CENTER ON
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION INTO THESE
HEARING. TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY
IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN WE
ARE HAVING TO PHYSICALLY
DISTANT AND PERSON HEARING. WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS AND MINIMAL CONTINGENT
A STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PUBLIC. AND LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND THE MEDIA SO WE
CAN KEEP SIXTIES A SPACING.
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL THIS IS A
PROTOCOL FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS WHEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAINST BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK. THEY WILL
RAISE THEIR HAND AND I WILL ASK
THEM TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
WILL ALSO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
VIA TELEPHONE. WE WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER WE'VE
HEARD ALL ITEMS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCE EAST AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR YOU PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
WHEN'S YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
THAT OUR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT.
THE POLICE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
THIS NOTHING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. THE PANELISTS L. A. O.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ARE PAYING REMOTELY TODAY. I
ASK THAT EVERYONE SILENCE
ELECTRONIC DEVICES AND FEET
MEET MEET YOURSELF WHEN YOU'RE
NOT SPEAKING. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTE IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL FOCUS ON
THE RECENT REPORT FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REGARDINGCDC
OURS NEWS THAT COMPLAIN PROCESS.
WILL ALSO BE GETTING A
RESPONSE- DEPARTMENT AND
DISCUSS THE REMAINING BUDGET
PROPOSAL THEY HAVE SUBMITTED.
IN RECENT HISTORY THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS HAD MULTIPLE
HEARINGS REGARDING CDCR STAFF
COMPLAIN PROCESS. THE
DEPARTMENT ADOPTED A NEW
PROCESS LAST YEAR AFTER HEARING
CONCERNS FROM LEGISLATORS AND
ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING CAR
THIRTY PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
REGARDING BIAS. QUALITY CONTROL
AND OVERALL FAIRNESS OF THE
PROCESSES. BASED ON THE DATA
AND FINDINGS IN THE REPORT FROM
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL THOSE
CONCERNS STILL REMAIN. WELL WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT A FAIR INDEPENDENT PROCESS
LOOKS LIKE BOTH TO THE ACCUSER
AND THE ACCUSED THE QUESTION OF
HOW TO DEAL WITH PERVASIVE
VIOLENT. AND OFTEN THE
HUMANIZING CULTURE THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
FITS EASILY INTO LET'S SAY THE
SOLUTION. WHAT WE CAN DO IS
PROMOTED AS SAFER ENVIRONMENT
THAT PROMOTES REHABILITATION
WHICH WE KNOW SAFER FOR STAFF.
AND SO THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
RELEASED FROM PRISON THEY LEAVE
BETTER NOT WORSE. THEY SHOULD
BE FOR US CREATE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL LIABILITY FOR THE
STATE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT
HAS DEEP CIVIL AND HUMAN RIGHTS
IMPLICATIONS. THANK YOU ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR A DREAM TO BE
HERE TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION. AFTER
EACH PANEL I WILL OPEN IT UP
FOR SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. OUR FIRST ISSUE
TODAY'S A SPECIAL REVIEW OF THE
STATUS CONTACT PRESS PROCESS
AND WE HAVE- OFF ON THE ARM
FROM FOR COMPLIANCE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
PRESENTING AT COULD PLEASE-
GIVE YOUR NAME WHEN YOU START
SPEAK. LET'S BEGIN. CONCERT
WITH CAITLIN. WE CAN'T HEAR YOU
CAITLYN. NO NO FEDERAL MEDICARE
F. CAITLYN. TWO TWENTY HELLO
THIS IS THIS IS CAITLIN O'NEILL
WITH THE L. A. O. WE HEAR YOU
NOW OKAY GREAT. I'LL GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IT IS KILLING
GALLAGHER L. A. O. FOR THE
RECORD AT THE VERY STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF ANALYZING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE
CONTEXT OF INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT THAT- WHICH RECENTLY
CAME OUT. BUT AT THIS POINT
WE'D LIKE TO PROVIDE THREE
PIECES OF BACKGROUND
INFORMATION FOR MEMBERS
AWARENESS FIRST- REPORTS OF
SERIOUS OFFICER MISCONDUCT ARE
NOT NEW AND HAVE BEEN REPORTED
AT SEVERAL PRISONS BY MULTIPLE
REPUTABLE SOURCES INCLUDING
INSPECTOR GENERAL COURT EXPERTS
ANY EASIER ON STAFF. FOR
EXAMPLE AFTER VISITING- RICHARD
J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY IN SAN DIEGO IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS A PART OF A STRIKE
TEAM SENT BY CDCR TO INTERVIEW
INMATES- REGARDING THE
ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT. THE
SHERIFF CHIEF OMBUDSMAN ROPE TO
CDCR LEADERSHIP EXPRESSING
GRAVE CONCERN URGING MEDIA
RESPONSE AND NOTING THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS. WERE THE WORST SHE
HEARD IN HER CAREER. SECOND CAN
ABOUT CDC- THE BILLING TO HAND
STAFF MISCONDUCT ARE ALSO NEW.
AND HAVE ALSO BEEN RAISED BY
MULTIPLE REPUTABLE STAKEHOLDERS
AT SOURCES IN ADDITION TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHO YOU'LL
HEAR FROM AFTER ME ON THE PANEL
TODAY. FOR EXAMPLE IN A REPORT
TO CDC OUR LEADERSHIP IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE- STRIKE TEAM THAT
WENT TO RJD. CONCLUDED THAT
QUOTE IN THE ALLEGATIONS TAKEN
AS A WHOLE SEEM TO DESCRIBE AN
ENVIRONMENT WITH NO RELIEF
MECHANISM FOR INMATES WHO FEEL
MISTREATED BY CUSTODY STAFF.
MOREOVER AN EXPERT WITNESS IN
THE ARMSTRONG VERSUS NATION
CASE WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT IN A
MOMENT- WHO HAD WRITTEN THE USE
OF FORCE AND DISCIPLINE
SYSTEMS- IN JAILS AND PRISONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. STATED IN
COURT DECLARATION THAT CDCR
SYSTEM IS THE WORST HE'S SEEN
IN HIS CAREER. I'M MOREOVER IT
CDCR APPEARS TO HAVE
DISREGARDED CONCERNS RAISED BY
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. IN THE
COURSE OF PROMULGATING
REGULATIONS FOR THE NEW ORLEANS
PROCESS WHICH COMPOUNDS UPON
THAT. CONCERNS ABOUT CITIES
HERE'S ABILITY TO HANDLE STAFF
MISCONDUCT ISSUES. AND THIRD
THIRD IT IS INVOLVED IN ONGOING
LITIGATION ON BOTH THE
ALLEGATIONS THERE IS OFTEN
MISCONDUCT AND THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO HANDLE IT
APPROPRIATE. SEVEN MILLION IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY PLAINTIFFS IN
ARMSTRONG VERSUS NEW SANDWICH
IS AN ONGOING CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT RELATED TO TREATMENT OF
INMATES WITH DISABILITIES-
ALLEGE THAT OFFICERS AT RJD ARE
ASSAULTING A CONFUSING AND
RETALIATING AGAINST INMATES
WITH DISABILITIES- AND THAT THE
PRISON SYSTEM FOR RESPONDING TO
THESE ALLEGATIONS IS AN
ADEQUATE. IN SEPTEMBER THE
COURTS ORDERED CDCR TO DEVELOP
A PLAN TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS THAT RJD AND REQUIRED
THE PLAN INCLUDES CERTAIN
ELEMENTS SUCH AS BODY WORN
CAMERAS- WHICH IS. WHICH LED
INTO THE P. C. P. WILL BE TO
START HEARING ABOUT LATER- AND
FINALLY IN JUNE PLAINTIFFS IN
THAT LAWSUIT FILED A MOTION
ALLEGING THAT THIS MISCONDUCT
AND INADEQUATE SYSTEMS FOR
HANDLING IT. IS SYSTEMIC AND
REQUESTING STATEWIDE RELIEF
HOWEVER THE COURT IS STILL
CONSIDERING THIS THIS MOTION.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
COMMENT HAVE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. SIX OF THE
PARTICULAR AT THE END WE'RE
GOING TO GO NEXT TO OUR
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THE-
MISTER WESLEY IF YOU COULD JUST
START SPEAKING SHOULD COME ON
SCREEN POINT YOU START SPEAKING.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HI I'M ROY WESLEY THE
CALIFORNIA INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY TO BRIEF YOU ON THE O. I.
G. REVIEW OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION PROCESS. FOR
REVIEWING AND INVESTIGATING
INCARCERATED PERSONS
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
AND THE FORMATION OF THE NEW
UNIT TO HANDLE SUCH ALLEGATIONS
CALLED. THE ALLEGATION ENQUIRY
MANAGEMENT SECTION. I WILL
FOCUS TODAY ON A TOP LEVEL
OVERVIEW. THE PROCESS WE LOOKED
AT CAME ABOUT AS A RESULT OF A
REVIEW MY OFFICE COMPLETED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON. AT
THE TIME WE WERE ASKED BY THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE TO LOOK AT HOW THESE
GRIEVANCES WERE PROCESSED AT
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON. WE
FOUND A SYSTEM THAT WAS UTTERLY
AND COMPLETELY BROKEN. THE
INCREASE CONDUCTED AT SALINAS
VALLEY WERE RIFE WITH BOTCHED
INTERVIEWS OFFICER BIAS AND NO
SEMBLANCE OF FAIRNESS. AS A
RESULT OF THAT REVIEW. WE MADE
A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE DEPARTMENT INCLUDING
REMOVING THE WARDENS AND
INSTITUTION STAFF FROM THIS
PROCESS. REGIONALIZED THE
PROCESS JUST AS THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS HAS REGIONALI
STATES MISCONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS. USE TRAINED
INVESTIGATORS TO COMPLETE THESE
ENCOURAGED AND CREATE AN AUDIT
FUNCTION TO ENSURE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION RESULTING FROM INQUIRIES
WERE ACTUALLY APPLIED. THE
REPORT WE WROTE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN LED TO THIS COMMITTEE
HOLDING A HEARING ON THIS ISSUE
ALMOST EXACTLY TWO YEARS AGO.
ALLOW ME TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE DEPARTMENT'S RESPONSE TO
THESE ISSUES DURING THE HEARING
IN THEIR OWN WORDS. THE
DEPARTMENT PROFESS TO AGREE
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
MY OFFICE MADE IN THE REPORT.
SINCE WE DO AGREE THAT THE
STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS DOES
NEED TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
PRISON ITSELF. WE DO NEED TO
HAVE- THE INVESTIGATORS- THE
TRAIN THE STAFF SO THEY CAN DO
INDEPENDENT INQUIRIES ON THEIR
OWN OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON
SETTING. I WOULD PERMIT
REPRESENTED THAT THE INCREASE
WOULD BE REMOVED. TAX COURT.
THE INCREASE WOULD BE REMOVED
FROM THE INSTITUTIONS AND THAT
WARDENS WOULD BE OUT OF THE
PROCESS CLICK HERE. FIVE COULD
IT. BUT IF WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT ADDING RESOURCES WE
HAVE TO HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE THAT THOSE RESOURCES
ARE GONNA HAVE A FACT THAT HAVE
AFFECTED NOW AND LEAD INTO THE
RECEIPT OF THE CONVERSATION
THAT THAT WERE THAT WERE ALSO
HAVING. AND REALLY HAPPY HAVE
THE IMPACT OF REHABILITATION
THAT WE HELP THE PRISON
SYSTEMS. ARE AND REALLY CAMBY.
I AGREE WITH I AGREE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK- SO
FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT NOTED
THAT THE PROCESS HAD BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS CLIPS. THIS
SITUATION YOU AND SORT OF
ALLUDED THAT YOU CHANGED SOME
POLICIES CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH THOSE POLICY CHANGES
AND IF YOU CAN SHARE HOW THOSE
WERE IMPLEMENTED WITH THOSE
DONE IN A IN ORDER AND A MEMO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A COPY OF
THAT AS WELL WE CAN GET YOU
SOME OF THOSE DOCUMENTS BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHANGES LIKE I SAID EARLIER.
WAS MOVING THE STAFF COMPLAINT
PROCESS OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON
AND PUTTING IT UNDER OUR OFFICE
OF OVERSIGHT AND RESEARCH AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT'S
REALLY THAT'S UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF WORLD- THE JOURNAL
AFFAIRS EXISTS. SO IT'S UP.
UNFORTUNATELY AS A REPORT
DOCUMENTS THESE PROMISES WERE
NOT FULFILLED. BY THE
CONCLUSION OF THAT HEARING I
WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH
THREE BROAD POINTS. NUMBER ONE.
WARDENS UNDERMINE THE PURPOSE
OF AIMS BY NOT REFERRING CASES
AND KEEPING INCREASE WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION. NUMBER TO THAT
DEPARTMENT HAS LIKELY GROSSLY
UNDERCOUNTED THE ACTUAL NUMBER
OF ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. WHEN WARDEN SIMPLY
RE CATEGORIZE COMPLAINTS FROM
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
TO ROUTINE APPEALS. AND FINALLY
WARDENS RARELY FOUND MERIT IN
THE ALLEGATIONS THEY RESOLVED
ESSENTIALLY EXONERATING THEIR
STAFF MORE THAN 98% OF THE TIME.
IN A 200-019-2000 TWENTY BUDGET
THE DEPARTMENT REQUESTED FORTY
SEVEN POSITIONS AT NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS NON GOING
FUNDING. THAT REQUEST WAS
GRANTED AND THE DEPARTMENT
STOOD UP THE ALLEGATION ENQUIRY
MANAGEMENT SECTION TO
INVESTIGATE INCARCERATED
PERSONS ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. IN THEIR REQUEST
FOR FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT
PROMISED THAT THIS NEW UNIT
WOULD PERFORM FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR INCREASE PER
MONTH. EQUALING FIVE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY INCREASE
PER YEAR. WE REVIEWED THE
ACTIVITIES OF AIMS FOR THE FIVE
MONTH PERIOD FROM APRIL FIRST
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THROUGH
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS WAS A
PERIOD WHEN AIMS WAS FULLY
FUNCTIONAL. DURING THIS FIVE
MONTH PERIOD THE UNIT ACCEPTED
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
ENQUIRIES FOR ABOUT ONE FIFTH
OF WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
HANDLE. IN FACT WARDENS
DETERMINED TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE GRIEVANCES
DURING THIS PERIOD ALLEGED
STAFF MISCONDUCT. ACCORDING TO
ITS OWN ANALYSIS WHEN
REQUESTING THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FOR AIMS. THE UNIT
COULD HAVE HANDLED ALL OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS. IF AIMS HAD
FULFILLED ITS PROMISE IN THE
NUMBER OF INCREASE THAT WOULD
HANDLE THE ANNUALIZED COST PER
ENQUIRY WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS. BASED ON THE
WORK THEY ACTUALLY DID THE
ANNUALIZED COST PER ENQUIRY
IT'S APROXIMATELY NINE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
DOLLARS PER. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT
ASSERTED THAT THE WARDENS AND
INSTITUTIONS WORK OUT OF THIS
PROCESS HOWEVER. UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT'S REGULATIONS THAT
THEY DEVELOPED AS A RESULT OF
OUR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
REPORT. WARDEN'S REMAINS
CENTRAL TO THIS PROCESS WARDENS
OR THEIR CHIEFS REVIEW EVERY
CLAIM THAT POTENTIALLY CLAIMS
CONTAINS ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT FILED BY
INCARCERATED PERSONS. AND
DETERMINE WHETHER THE CLAIM
MEETS THE DEPARTMENT'S
DEFINITION OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
AND WHETHER IT WILL BE REFERRED
OUTSIDE THE PRISON. NOTHING
GETS REFERRED AIMS FOR INQUIRY
WITHOUT A WORD AND MAKING THE
REFER. AS I SAID CONTRARY TO
WHAT WAS INSERTED AT THE
HEARING BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
ALMOST TWO YEARS AGO WARDENS
AND THE INSTITUTIONS ARE MOST
ASSUREDLY NOT OUT OF THIS
PROCESS. AS I NOTED EARLIER
WARDENS IDENTIFIED TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE
GRIEVANCES AT STAFF MISCONDUCT
DURING OUR REVIEW PERIOD.
HOWEVER THE ONLY REFERRED 23%
OF THOSE CASES TO AIMS. THEY
HANDLE THE BALANCE OF THE 77%
OF THE CASES INTERNALLY AT THE
PRISONS. IN ADDITION WE HAVE
UNCOVERED EVIDENCE THAT THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE GRIEVANCES
IDENTIFIED BY WORDS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. IS GROSSLY
UNDERCOUNTED. WE SUSPECT THAT
INCARCERATED PERSONS FILED
THOUSANDS MORE ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT IN THE
DEPARTMENT SYSTEMS SHOW. UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE PROCESS
THE DEVELOPED BY THE DEPARTMENT
AGREEMENTS IS FIRST REVIEWED BY
A GRIEVANCE COORDINATOR. WHO
REFUSED TO SEE IF THERE IS AN
ALLEGATION OF STAFF MISCONDUCT.
AFTER THAT REVIEW THE GRIEVANCE
GOES FOR FINAL REVIEW BY THE
WORK. WITH HER OR NOT WITH THE
GRIEVANCE COORDINATOR THAT THE
GRIEVANCE ALLEGES STAFF
MISCONDUCT. WARDENS
COUNTERMANDED THEIR GRIEVANCE
COORDINATOR 65% OF THE TIME.
AND FOUND ONLY 35% OF THE
GRIEVANCE GRIEVANCES FORWARDED
TO THEM ALLEGED STAFF
MISCONDUCT. THE GRIEVANCE THAT
WERE NOT FOUND TO BE STAFF
MISCONDUCT CLAIMS WERE SIMPLY
RE CATEGORIZED BY THE WHARTON
AS ROUTINE APPEALS. NEXT A FULL
TWO YEARS AFTER SURE INCE'S
WERE GIVEN TO THIS COMMUNITY
THIS COMMITTEE NO AUDIT
FUNCTION IS ANYWHERE IN SIGHT.
THE DEPARTMENT NOT ONLY HAS NO
VISIBILITY ON WHETHER THE
GRIEVANCE PROCESS IS WORKING OR
NOT THE DEPARTMENT HAS NO
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS ITSELF TO
PRODUCE REPORTS IDENTIFYING
OFFICERS WHO HAVE BEEN IF YOU
KEEP THIS CONTENT. OFFICERS WHO
HAD THOSE ACCUSATIONS
CORROBORATED. FOR WHO HAVE BEEN
PUNISHED. FINALLY JUST AS THE
SALINAS VALLEY TWO YEARS AGO
THIS PROCESS EXONERATE STAFF AT
AN ASTONISHING WORKED STAFF
WERE EXONERATED NINETY EIGHT
POINT 3% OF THE TIME IN THE
CASES LOOK AT EITHER BY AIMS
ARE THOSE HANDLED IN HOUSE WITH
THE PRESENTS. IN FACT UNDER
THIS PROCESS THE RATE OF
EXONERATIONS EXCEEDS WHAT WE
FOUND AT SALINAS VALLEY TWO
YEARS AGO. INSTEAD OF WHAT WAS
PROMISED TWO YEARS AGO THE
DEPARTMENT. DESIGNED A SYSTEM
WITH MANY OFF RAMPS. THAT
PREVENT A FAIR AND INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION OF AN MADE
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. DESPITE PROFESSING
TO AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
IMPLEMENTED FEW IF ANY OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. OF NOTE THE
SECRETARY AND I HAD A VERY
POSITIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THESE ISSUES LAST WEEK AND IN
RESPONSE TO HERBAGE INVITATION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO COLLABORATING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON THESE
AND OTHER ISSUES. THANK YOU AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. WITH
THANK YOU OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS
FROM CDC ARE. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE KATHLEEN ALISON
SECRETARY FOR CDC ARE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
TODAY TO ADDRESS THIS VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE. THIS ISSUE OF
OUR APPEALS AND GRIEVANCE
PROCESS- TO INCLUDE STAFF
COMPLAINTS IT'S VERY NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART WHEN I WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
I INITIATED EVEN BEFORE THE O.
R. G. REPORT TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO START THE PROCESS.
TO REVAMP OUR APPEALS. I KNEW
THIS FROM MY NAY YEARS
EXPERIENCE IN. THE NUMBER OF
STAFF COMPLAINTS OF THE NUMBER
OF INMATE APPEALS. THAT HAVE
FINDING VERSUS THE NUMBER OF
ADVERSE ACTIONS. DIDN'T MATCH
UP THE ADVERSE ACTIONS FAR
EXCEEDED THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS THAT HAVE FINDINGS
TO WARDENS IN THE END TRYING TO
THEIR TO DO A RIGHT THING C. C.
R. TAKES EVERY ALLEGATION OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND WE ARE COMMITTED
TO ENSURING ALL ALLEGATIONS ARE
PROPERLY FAIRLY AND THOROUGHLY
REVIEWED. WE WELCOME THE
OFFICERS INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REVIEW AND THIS IS MISTER
WESLEY SAID HE AND I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS AND I
APPRECIATE HIS VERY THOROUGH
REPORT I FIND IT INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE INSIGHT ON THE STATUS
OF OUR CURRENT PROCESS OF
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST STAFF. BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
AGENCY HAS DEMONSTRATED A
COMMITMENT TO SEEK OUTSIDE
INDEPENDENT REVIEWS OVERSTAFFED
COMPLAINT PROCESS BY THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL THIS IS
EVIDENT BY- OUR REQUEST FOR THE
O. I. G. TO CONDUCT A THOROUGH
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON
REVIEW WHICH PROMPTED THE
JANUARY. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
I. G. REPORT. WE CHECK THOSE
FINE OF THAT REPORT VERY
SERIOUSLY TOOK STEPS TO
INITIATE. AND IMPLEMENT VERY
SURE RIGHT. IT SURE OF OUR
ALLEGATION ACQUIRING SYSTEM
WHICH AS MR WESLEY STATED IT
WAS APPROXIMATELY TEN MILLION
IN FUNDING AND FORTY SEVEN
POSITIONS THIS PROCESS BEGAN TO
ROLL OUT IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY WITH FULL IMPLEMENTATION
IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
YOU'RE IN THE THROES OF CODE
NINETEEN. IT IS AN IMPROVEMENT
FROM WHERE WE WERE BUT IT WAS
NOT WITHOUT FLAWS. ACTIVATION
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED OF THE MOST
SERIOUS STAFF ALLEGATIONS HAVE
BEEN REVIEWED COMPLETED.
INDEPENDENT BY TRAIN TO INQUIRE
STAFF TRAINED STAFF IN OUR
AGENT JUST AS THE- I. G. WAS
EVALUATING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF OUR NEW PROCESS AND
ACTIVATION OF AIMS WE WERE TO
EVALUATING AND CORRECTING ALONG
THE WAY. IT IS TRUE THE
SITUATION REVIEWING THAT THE
ALREADY AND GRIEVANCE
COORDINATOR HAVE STRUGGLED WITH
THE SCREENING. SAYS PUT IN
PLACE AND CONFUSION LIKELY
RESULTED AND SHE WERE
ALLEGATIONS BEING SENT TO
ENHANCE TO ADDRESS INTERNAL
REVIEWS AND IMMEDIATE ACTION
HAVE BEEN UNDER WAY THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS. BOTTOM LINE IS WE
NEEDED TO COMPLEX. WE CONTINUE
TO HOST REGULAR INTERACTIVE
CONFERENCES WITHIN BETWEEN UNIT
FORTIES AND GRIEVANCE
COORDINATORS TO ADDRESS
PARTICULAR ISSUES I'M NOT. YOU
HAVE ALSO DONE A REVIEW OF THE
PROPER APPLICATION OF REFERRALS
TO WHAT THE L. A. G. IS AN
ADULT. TWO OTHER WHICH HE HAS
DONE ALLOWING US TO EDUCATE
CORRECT THE ERRORS AS WE FIND
THEM. ADDITIONALLY WE FIND THE
AMOUNT OF TIMES ON EACH AIMS
ENQUIRING. FOREXTV REGIONAL
ESTIMATES THREE FULL TO
ADDRESS. WE HAVE. A CURRENT
TIME AND MOTION STUDY OF THE
AIM SCREENING AND COREY PROCESS
UNDER WAY WITH THE GOAL OF
IDENTIFYING EFFICIENCIES. WITH
ALL OF THIS WE EXPECTED VOLUME
AIMS TO INCREASE AND WE EXPECT
TO FIND EFFICIENCIES IN AMES
PROCESS. THIS WILL PROVIDE US A
MUCH MORE ACCURATE PICTURE. OF
THE ONGOING WORKLOAD NEEDS AND
COMMITMENT TRISH TORTURED
FINDINGS BASED ON ARMED
ASSESSMENT AS WELL AS- YG'S TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE REPORT. THERE ARE SOME
IMMEDIATE ACTIONS THAT ARE
BEING ADDRESSED. FIRST SHIFTED
INCONSISTENCIES OF APPLICATION
THE COMPLEXITIES OF THE
SCREENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I
HAVE DIRECTED MY TEAM. TO AN
IMMEDIATE STRATEGY TO IMPLEMENT
A STATE WIDE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING PROCESS FOR ALL
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST STAFF
RECEIVED BY THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF PRIYA WHICH ALREADY HAS A
VERY ROBUST PROCESS MONITORED
BY THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
AUDITED BY- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT REQUIRES REAL
TIME ANALYSIS TO COLLECT
EVIDENCE- AND THIS PROCESS IS
WELL ESTABLISHED ALL THE WAY
ACROSS THE NATION. THIS WILL
PROVIDE A SINGLE INDEPENDENT
SOURCE TO ENSURE THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS ARE CORRECTLY
APPLIED IN DETERMINING WHETHER
STAFF MISCONDUCT SHOULD BE
DEFERRED FOR PROCESSING AND
REMOVES THE PROCESS FROM LOCAL
CONTROL. THIS WILL ALLOW ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF EXCESSIVE AND
UNNECESSARY USE OF FORCE THIS
WILL ALLOW FOR THE LOCAL
GRIEVANCE COORDINATOR SHOULD
SIMPLY FORWARD ANY GRIEVANCE
RECEIVED THAT IS A STAFF
COMPLAINED TO THE STATE WIDE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING UNIT TO
PROCESS AND FORWARD TO THE
CORRECT AREA. OUR CURRENT
PRACTICE TO THIS POINT HAS BEEN
FOR THE LOCAL INSTITUTIONS TO
DETERMINE IF A STAFF COMPLAINTS.
WHAT'S FOUND TRUE M. WOULD
LIKELY- RESULT IN ADVERSE
ACTION THIS IS A COMPLEX
ANALYSIS. AND THEREFORE I THINK
PART OF THE PROBLEM. THIS
COMMITMENT OF A CENTRALIZED
SCREENING THE LOCAL
INSTITUTIONS NO LONGER HAVE TO
APPLY THIS COMPLEX SCREENING
CRITERIA AND ENSURE ALL STAFF
COMPLAINTS GOES TO AN
INDEPENDENT OUTSIDE AREA. TO
APPLY TO STANDARD SECONDLY. WE
CURRENTLY PROCESS ALLEGATIONS
OF EXCESSIVE UNNECESSARY FORCE
WITH SERIOUS BODILY INJURY. GO
TO GAME RECOGNIZING THEIR
RESPONSE INJURY DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR ALL INJURIES
OUTSIDE OF THE DHINAC
DEFINITION ESPIANDO. THEREFORE
THE FIRST STEP I DIRECTED MY
CHANGE INSTITUTE AND EXPAND ON
THIS PROCESS ALL ALLEGATIONS OF
EXCESSIVE OR UNNECESSARY FORCE
WITH ANY INJURY. ARE TO BE
REFERRED JAMES AND I COLLUDED-
THOSE THAT DO NOT NEED TO
INCLUDE THOSE THAT CURRENTLY DO
NOT MEET THE SB I'D ALREADY ARE
YOU SUPPORT PROCESSES ARE
MIRRORED BY THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL THEY MONITOR
THEM IN A REAL TIME OUR REVIEW
PROCESS. ARGUMENT THAT AS WELL.
THIRD I HAVE DIRECTED MY FOR
TO. AND APPLIANCES WERE AIMS
WILL PROVIDE A CLEAR.
CONCLUSION WHICH WILL INDICATE
TO OUTCOMES ONE A THOROUGH AND
COMPLETE IN CARD HAS BEEN
COMPLETED THAT INCLUDES ALL
FACTS AND EVIDENCE. THEY
BELIEVE AVAILABLE TO REASONABLE
MISCONDUCT HAS OCCURRED WHICH
WILL LEAD TO ADVERSE ACTION.
WHEN REASONABLE BELIEF IS
ACIEVED. AND BURST OUT AND OUR
PROCESS A REQUEST FOR AN
INVESTIGATION WILL BE INITIATED
BY THE AMES TEAM FOR THE HIRING
AUTHORITY THIS WILL ALLOW THE
CASE TO MOVE SWIFTLY FROM
REQUIRE RETURN DESTINATION. MY
EXPECTATION IS THAT THE HARNESS
OR THE LOCAL LEVEL DISAGREES
REQUEST FOR INVESTIGATION
FACIAL IMMEDIATELY EVALUATE
THAT TO THE AMES CHIEF FOR A
RESOLUTION ALLOWING FOR
MONITORING OVERSIGHT AND THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL. AND ANY
FURTHER AND I JUST THIS
AGREEMENT WILL BE RAISED TO THE
ASSOCIATE. DIRECTOR OF GLOBAL.
I THINK THIS IS AND- BECAUSE I
WILL SAY AFTER REVIEWING MANY
OF THE AIMS- REPORTS. IT'S A
LOT OF WORDS I MEAN I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WHAT
INSTITUTIONS I ISSUE STAFF
SKEWS ME INVESTIGATORS STYLE
ROAD REPORT. AND IF THERE WAS A
LOT OF INFORMATION WITH NO REAL
CONCLUSION- AND SOMETIMES WE
MISS THE NEXT OBVIOUS QUESTION.
AND I'M I'M VERY COMMITTED TO
US BEING DEPARTMENT OF
INTEGRITY AND HAVING THIS
PROCESS BE VERY THOROUGH. IN
ADDITION TO THE FIRST THREE
ACTIONS WE AGREE THAT THE
DEFINITION OF THE STAFF
COMPLAINT REQUIRES MODIFICATION.
CREATE A MORE EFFECTIVE
PROCESS. DOING CHOIR STAFFEL
CONSIDERATION AS TO NOT FIX ONE
PROBLEM AND INADVERTENTLY
CREATE ANOTHER THEREFORE I
DIRECTED STAFF. TO AND TO DO
THIS EFFICIENTLY AND TO SEEK
INPUT. NOT ONLY THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL BUT THE
LEGISLATURE I'M FINE YOUR STAFF
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH REGULAR
MEETINGS- TO BE BRIEFED OR SIT
AT THE TABLE AS WE WORK THROUGH
AND IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS. WE'RE READY. ABOUT
THE LIMITATIONS OF ALLEGATIONS-
MORE THAN THIRTY DAYS AFTER
ALLEGED INCIDENT SO I ASKED TO
HAVE THAT EVALUATED CURRENTLY
THE PROCESS AND IF IT'S BEYOND
THIRTY DAYS- WHEN AN OFFENDER
TURNS IT TO THE AIMS UNIT IN
AND SENT BACK TO THE
INSTITUTION FOR ANALYSIS SO WE-
ARE IN THE PROCESS. YEAH MY
STAFF. J. OTHER JURISDICTIONS
WILL BEST TRACK. FURTHER THE
DEPARTMENT RECOGNIZE THAT THE-
MULTIPLE ISOLATED DATA SYSTEMS
ARE NOT UP TO. MAKING REPORTS.
YEAH DIFFICULT AND FOR DUE TO
THE FOCUS OF HOPE AND MANY
THINGS- THAT WAS NOT A PRIORITY
DURING DURING TWO THOUSAND
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS FOCUSED
ON KOBE. SO WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
DEDICATE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY- TO ADDRESSING THE
DATA SYSTEMS ASCOCHYTA IS
RESOLVING WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS WITH LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED CASES TODAY.
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
FINDING AN IT SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM ONCE ONCE AND FOR ALL.
I AM COMMITTED TO HAVING THESE
ITEMS REVIEWED SWIFTLY. AND
THOROUGHLY. BINARY TREE SHAPE
THE SUPPORT. OF THIS COMMITTEE
ON TRAINING ANALYSTS AND
CAROLERS IN OUR REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL CAMERAS AT R. J. D.
AND L. A. C. FOR FACILITIES BE
ANTI. WHICH IS INCLUDED IN OUR
ARMSTRONG PROPOSAL I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT ADDITIONAL CAMERAS
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFIT
REDUCING STAFF COMPLAINS. WE
HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND THE
BENEFIT OF CAMERAS AT OUR
FACILITIES SPECIFICALLY AT HIGH
DESERT AND CCW OUT FOR- IN
CHOWCHILLA CALIFORNIA CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY.
CRISTINA MARKET DECREASE AN
ALLEGATION ENQUIRE RES- CAMERAS
MAKE EVERYBODY BEHAVE SO I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THOSE THOSE
EFFORTS- GOING FORWARD. IN THE
COURT ORDER FOR BODY WORN
CAMERAS AT RJD WE ARE READY TO
BE AMONG THE FIRST CORRECTIONAL
ENVIRONMENT TO DEPLOY AND
ASSESS THE USE OF BODY CAMERAS.
WHICH UP TO THIS POINT HAVE
BEEN RELATIVELY SMALL FOOTPRINT
IN A CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM. IT IS
DIFFERENT FROM MORE ESTABLISHED
LANDSCAPE OF COMMUNITY POLICE
DEPARTMENTS. I WANT TO
REITERATE TO THE COMMITTEE. MY
RECOGNITION IS THAT THERE'S-
WATCH TO IMPROVE IN THIS
CURRENT PROCESS AS LAID OUT BY
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT
MY COMMITMENT TO CREATE A SWIFT
<c.green>HANGE AND IMPROVE THE</c>
PROCESSES AND MY OPENNESS TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WHILE
DOING SO. I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER. TO OUR FISCAL SERVICES
DIRECTOR ERIC SWANSON DIRECTOR
AMY AND ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR SPAN
RIGHT TO BELIEVE. PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR ARMSTRONG
COMPLAINTS PROPOSAL. AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AN ERIC SWANSON
I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES CDCR
REQUEST THIRTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AT
TWENTY TWO POINT EIGHT
POSITIONS TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THE DIFFERING AMOUNTS IN
FUTURE YEARS TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS ORDERED BY THE
UNITED STATES DISTRICT COURT IN
ARMSTRONG VERSUS NEWSOME. THERE
ARE FOUR COMPONENTS TO THIS
REQUEST WHICH WILL GO OVER VERY
BRIEFLY AND THEN WE HAVE AB
MILLER IGNORANCE ABOUT WHO WILL
TALK ABOUT TWO OF THOSE. WE ARE
PROPOSING TO EXPAND CITIES
HERE'S AUDIO VISUAL
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM TO RICHARD
J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY AND SPECIFIED YARDS.
BY CAL TATE PRISON LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. THIS FOLLOWS SIX CENTS
WOULD LIMITATION OF OUR HIGH
DESERT. AND CC F. W.
INSTITUTION WITH. THIS PROPOSAL
ON MY CAR PRIOR AB ACCESS OR
STANDING CAMERA PROPOSALS IN
THE PAST ALSO INCLUDES A BODY
WORN CAMERA FOR EACH
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AND
SERGEANT IDENTIFIED RGD IS
HAVING REGULAR INTERACTION.
WITH INMATE ARMSTRONG CLASS
MEMBERS. OUR THIRD COMPONENT IS
A SUPERVISORY COMPONENTS
CONSISTING OF NINE CORRECTIONAL
SERGEANTS AND ONE CORRECTIONAL
JANET RGD THE STAFF WILL ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH NEWLY
ESTABLISHED GUIDELINES POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES. AND FINALLY OUR
PROPOSAL EXPANDS THE ALLEGATION
IN CREE MANAGEMENTS OF SECTION
WHICH WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. IN ORDER FOR THE STAFF
COMPLETE PROCESS OF RGD I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE AMY MILLER
WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT THE RGD
STAFF COMPLETE PROCESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS AMY MILLER AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONAL POLICY RESEARCH
AND INTERNAL OVERSIGHT. THE
ARMSTRONG COURT COMPLAINTS
REQUEST INCLUDES RESOURCES
BIRTH STAFF COMPLAINTS
SCREENING UNIT AND EXPANSION
FOR THE ALLEGATION ENQUIRY
MANAGEMENT SECTION SPECIFIC FOR
RJD. WITH SIX POINT EIGHT
POSITIONS REQUESTED A CURRENT
YEAR AND A TOTAL OF TEN
PERMANENT RESOURCES IN BUDGET
YEAR THIS REQUEST WILL ENSURE
ALL ALLEGATIONS AGAINST STAFF
RECEIVED BY RJD CAN BE SCREENED
BY AN EXTERNAL STAFF
ALLEGATIONS SCREENING ANALYST
DETERMINE WHERE THE INQUIRY OR
INVESTIGATION. SHALL BE
CONDUCTED ACCORDING TO POLICY
AND WILL EXPAND THE CATEGORIES
IN WHICH AIMS INQUIRY IS
COMPLETED ON WHAT WAS
ORIGINALLY PLANNED IN THE
ALLEGATION ENQUIRY MANAGEMENT
UNIT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET REQUEST- AND.
THESE CHANGES ARE SPECIFIC RJD.
OKAY THE FOLLOWING CATEGORIES.
ALL ALLEGATIONS UNNECESSARY
EXCESSIVE OR UNREPORTED USE OF
FORCE REGARDLESS OF INJURY. ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT TOWARD THAT MAKES.
ALL ALLEGATIONS OF
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
PROTECTED CLASS NUMBERS. AND
ALL ALLEGATIONS OF RETALIATION
FOR USING THE GRIEVANCE AND
APPEALS PROCESS. TO SUBMIT AN
ALLEGATION AGAINST STAFF. HIS
REQUEST MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THAT SEPTEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ARMSTRONG COURT ORDER
REQUIRING CDC ARE TO REFORM THE
STAFF COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION
AND DISCIPLINE PROCESS THAT RJD
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT CDC ARE
COMPLETELY UNBIASED
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION
INTO ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT VIOLATED. THE RIGHTS
OF ANY CLASS MEMBER UNDER THE
ARMSTRONG REMEDIAL PLAN OR THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT.
AND INCLUDES EFFECTIVE
MECHANISMS FOR OVERSIGHT
OVERSTAFFED COMPLAINTS USE OF
FORCE REVIEWS AND RELATED STAFF
DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS AND
RJD THAT INVOLVE ALLEGED
VIOLATIONS OF CLASS MEMBERS
RIGHT UNDER THE ARMSTRONG
REMEDIAL PLAN. ANY AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITY ACT. I WOULD
LIKE TO NOW. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
MARION SPEARMINT WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE OVERVIEW OF THE
CAMERA REQUEST INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR OF MEMBERS A COMMUNITY
MARION'S TREMENDOUS SOCIAL
DIRECTOR OF CDC ARE. IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY UNITED
STATES DISTRICT COURTORDERED
C. C. R. AND ARMSTRONG
LITIGATION TO STALL
SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS IN ALL
AREAS OF THE RICHARD J. DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY OR INCAR
THREE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO.
EXERCISE YOUR RIGHTS HOUSING
UNITS SALLY PORTS DINING HALLS
PROGRAM AREAS GYMNASIUM'S
WITHIN NINETY DAYS. WE'RE ALSO
FURTHER OR TO SEE JERRY BIG
USING BODY WERE CAMERAS FOR ALL
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AT RG WHO
MAY HAVE INTERACTION WITH
PROTECTED. PASSWORD PROTECTED
CLASS MEMBERS WITHIN SIXTY
EIGHT SEE HERE ALSO ALSO THE
ORDER TO RETAIN ALL FOOTAGE
FROM ANOTHER NINETY DAYS AND
THE FOOTAGE OF USE OF FORCE AND
OTHER TRIGGERING EVENTS
INVOLVING ARMSTRONG MEAL PLAN
CLASSROOMS ARE EIGHTY WOULD BE
RETAINED INDEFINITELY. AND THAT
WAS ONE OF BAILABLE WILL BE
REVIEWED AND CONSIDERED AS PART
OF AN INVESTIGATION IN ANY
INCIDENT. THE DEPARTMENT WENT A
LITTLE FURTHER BE PROACTIVE I
MADE A DECISION TO REQUIRE
CORRECTIONAL SERGEANTS AT RGD
TO WEAR BODY WORN CAMERAS AS
THEY MAY HAVE INTERACTION WITH
PROTECTED CLASS MEMBERS. SO IN
JANUARY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE USE OF BODY WORN
CAMERAS WAS IMPLEMENTED AT THAT
PARK EIGHTY TWO AN INSTRUCTION
MEMORANDUM. ISSUED BY DIRECTOR
GIPSON PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION ALL CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS SERGEANTS LIEUTENANTS.
WERE PROVIDED TRAINING ON BODY
WORN CAMERAS. AND ALL THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
BREAKDOWN IS STILL BE NOT
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS- INCLUDING THE MINIMUM
SUPPORT FACILITY PERIMETER. AND
AREAS OF HAPPENED PROBLEM CON
CONGREGATION RJD. THEY WILL ALL
THEY ALSO HAVE BEEN SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE APPROX
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE BODY WORN
CAMERAS THERE BEING EMPLOYMENT
USE THERE AND THEN ALSO PART OF
THIS REQUESTED TO TOAST ALL TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE SIX CAMPUS
AT CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ON THE
CITY'S B. AND D. THE- C. C. R.
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BY.
THANK SECRETARY ALLISON WE
HAVE. AUDIO WE HAVE APS HAS
INSTALLED A HIGH DESERT AT-
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY AT SAN QUENTIN AT THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON SACRAMENTO.
IT'S BEEN DEPLOYED THERE IT'S
VERY BENEFICIAL WHEN IDENTIFIES
SUSPECTS IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS IT HELPS US WE
HAVE TO LOOK FOR A LOST OR
MISPLACED ITEMS WHICH- LEADS US
NOT TO HAVE VERY LONG TERM
LOCKDOWNS A MODIFIED PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE
AFFECT RESPECTFUL TO
REHABILITATE PROGRAMMING. HIS
SYSTEM AND SOMEONE ON THE
OUTSIDE THE RULES SOME TYPE OF
ITEM ON THE PRISON PROPERTY.
ESPECIALLY RUN A MINIMUM
SUPPORT FACILITIES AND WE THE
FORTY MAKING GOING TO RETRIEVE
THAT A CAMERA PICKS THAT UP. IT
HELPS ALSO TO DETERMINE THE
INTRODUCTION OF CONTRABAND INTO
A PRISON AND IDENTIFY EMPLOYEES
VOLUNTEERS CONTRACTORS
ATTORNEYS VISITORS AN INMATE'S
DISCOVER INTRODUCING.
CONTRABAND TO DEPRESSION. IT
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL DATA TO
REVIEW IF YOU DON'T
QUALIFICATIONS AT THE SORTES
THE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY VICTIMS. OF VIOLENCE
AND AGGRESSORS. BUT WORN
CAMERAS WITH MANY EARLIER NEW
TECH. DEPENDED LOW. THAT'S NOT
WIDELY CORRECTION SAY BY OTHER
ARE THE COUNTRY. RJD'S
IMPLEMENTATION WILL GIVE OUR
DEPARTMENT OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
EXPRESSIONISTIC. EVEN THOUGH BY
OUR CAMERAS ARE YOU NEW TO THE
CORRECTIONAL SETTING OUR
DEPARTMENT WE RELIC KNOWLEDGE
THAT THEY PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
IN RESOLVING ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT INAPPROPRIATE
USE OF FORCE ALLEGATIONS AND
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS
ALLEGATIONS. THEY PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DATA TO REVIEW IN
CONJUNCTION WITH INVESTIGATIONS
AGAIN OF AN INCIDENT. AND
LASTLY IF A BODY WORN CAMERAS
NOT ACTIVATED TO AN ENTIRE
SHIFT OF AN EMPLOYEE OR IS
INTENTIONALLY DEACTIVATE
OUTSIDE ESTABLISHED POLICY
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
COUPLE THINGS COULD HAPPEN ONE
OF SOME STAFF MEMBER HAS USED
THE RESTROOM MASSIVE ONE THAT'S
ONE OF OUR- AREAS FOR WORK A
PERSON CAN DEACTIVATE THEIR
CAMERAS IT WILL USE THE
BATHROOM. SOMEONE COMES OUT AND
THEYRESPOND IMMEDIATELY TO AN
ALARM THAT'S BEEN SENATOR ORRIN
INCIDENT IN FRONT OF THEM IN A
PROGRAM OFFICE ISN'T LIKE THAT.
THE AND THAT PERSON COULD
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL TRAINING ON
THE FLIP SIDE OF SOMEBODY
INTENTIONALLY DE ACTIVATE STAR
CAMERA IN SOME SORT OF INCIDENT
OF USE OF FORCE THAT'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BEHIND IT IT COULD
RESULT IN CORRECTIVE OR AT RISK
ACTION. AND SO WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THAT IS THE HIRING
AUTHORITY WAS AWARDED REVIEW
THAT AND THEY'LL MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ON THE
DISCIPLINE THAT HE MADE IT OUT.
AGAIN THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ARE ABLE
FULLER. A FEDERAL PANEL FOR
TODAY. IF. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD.
LISTEN HERE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS BUT FOR SURE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THOSE VIDEOS
WANT TO ASK THEM QUESTIONS TO
SOME I THINK A DEFERRED YOU
GUYS VERSUS THIS IS BEEN GOING
ON TO SEE IF I GOT HIM A SYSTEM
ON CHIP I HAD TO KICK IT OFF.
THANK YOU. SECRETARY ALISON
WITHOUT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
YOU HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
CREDIBILITY PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
ON THIS ISSUE GIVEN WHAT WE
WERE TOLD TWO YEARS AGO WHEN WE
APPROVE THIS MONEY HOW IT WAS
USED AND THE STANDARD THAT WAS
SET UP. TO USE THIS MONEY AND
TO ADDRESS. YOU MAKE COMPLAINTS
ABOUT STAFF ACTIONS IS JUST
ASTONISHING TO ME THAT THE.
EXCUSE OF IT BEING COMPLICATED
WHEN REALLY YOU IT SEEMS LIKE
THE SYSTEM WAS SET UP. WITH TOO
MANY GATES TO ENSURE THE
COMPLAINTS AND NEVER GOT TO THE
UNIT. AND NOW YOU'RE ACTUALLY
ASKING US FOR MORE MONEY. TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT FOR A SYSTEM
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
OVERSIGHT OVER COMPLAINT DRIVEN
SYSTEM. AND BY THAT JUST BY THE
NUMBER. THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORTS. A FIFTH OR
LESS OF THE EXPECTED ACTIVITY
HAPPENED WITH WHAT WE WERE
FUNDING. SO I HAVE TO ASK IN
THIS IS PROBABLY THE LEAST
SIGNIFICANT QUESTION IS WHERE
DID THE REST OF THE MONEY GO.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY AND SO
THAT THAT'S A BIG ISSUE THAT.
THAT IF WE ALLOCATE MONEY FOR
SOMETHING AND IT'S CLEARLY NOT
BEING SPENT THEIR IT IT'S BEEN
SPENT SOMEPLACE ELSE. WHEN YOU
COME BACK AND ASK FOR MORE
MONEY FOR SOMETHING. IT'S
REALLY HARD FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND. AND HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THAT MONEY WILL BE SPENT
ON ON HOW IT'S HOW YOU'RE
SAYING. I'M NOT SURE THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD ALLOW. MORE
MONEY TO FIX THE PROBLEM THAT
SHOULDN'T HAVE ARISEN IN THIS
WAY IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO
THAT'S A REAL CHALLENGE FOR ME
SITTING HERE RIGHT HERE NOW I
KNOW YOU CAN BE WORKING WITH-THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
ANOTHER SOME PROCESSES THAT
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND
TO BE CLEANED UP. SO FOR. HOW
MAY BE WILLING TO SPEND MORE
MONEY IN THIS AREA I THINK WE
REALLY REALLY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW. THIS IS GOING
TO BE FIXED. AND IT'S FAIRLY
CLEAR. THAT THERE ARE TOO MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE ABILITY OF
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
WARDENS TO HEAD OFF A COMPLAINT.
AND MAKE IT SEEM INSIGNIFICANT
WHEN IT MIGHT BE. AND SO YOU
YOU'VE GOT VARIOUS LEVELS OF
ACTUAL INTERFERENCE. WITH A
PROCESS THAT YOU DESIGN. AND
THAT WAS SOLD TO US AS BEING
WORTHY OF SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. WITH THE RHETORIC
THAT. WE SEEM TO HAVE HAD
AGREEMENT. ON WHAT WAS MOVING
FORWARD AND HOW IN THE AND THAT
TURNED OUT TO BE JUST NOT TRUE
SO I'M REALLY STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW. WITH HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD. AND HOW YOU ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SET UP A SYSTEM.
GIVEN THEIR INTERNALCULTURE
AND THE PROTECTIVE NATURE OF
YOUR POINT CURRENT EMPLOYMENT
STRUCTURE. THAT SEEMS TO
PREDETERMINE. OUTCOMES FROM
COMPLAINTS OR TO DISMISS
COMPLAINTS. ARBITRARILY WITHOUT
GIVING ANY REAL SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION TO WHAT TRULY
HAPPENED AND WHAT THE REMEDIES
ARE GOING TO BE. SO HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO. BE ABLE TO CONVINCE
US N. AND HOW TO RECOVER THE
CREDIBILITY HERE. IN A WAY THAT
THAT WE CAN. BOB IS REALLY
TRYING TO FIND A PATH TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH ALL OF THIS AND I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE THOSE
CHANGES MADE AND MADE NOW.
BEFORE YOU GONNA COME BACK TO
US TO ASK FOR MORE INFO FOR
MORE MONEY BECAUSE IT JUST
LOOKS TO ME LIKE MONEY THAT HAD
BEEN SPENT. FOR THE MONEY THAT
WE GAVE YOU HAS BEEN MISSPENT.
AND I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE
THIS PROCESS FIXED. AND FIXED
RIGHT AWAY. AND IN A WAY THAT
THAT IS TRACEABLE IS AUDIBLE IS
MANAGEABLE. AND THAT YOU CAN
SHOW SOME SIGNIFICANT OUTCOMES.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT ELSE TO
SUGGEST AS A WAY OF KIND OF
GETTING BACK SOME OF THAT
CREDIBILITY TO ME WHEN I READ
THIS I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT AND
THEN JUST SITTING HERE
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY. AND
THINKING BACK TO THE HEARINGS
FROM A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I'M
JUST ASTONISHED THAT WE'RE IN
THIS PLACE. SO IF YOU WANT OUR
HELP HELP US HELP YOU BUT
YOU'VE GOT A LONG WAYS TO GO TO
SHOW HOW THE SYSTEM CAN BE
FIXED CAN BE ADDRESSED AND THAT
WE CAN GET IT TO EVEN BEGIN TO
LOOK LIKE WHAT WAS PROMISED
WHEN THIS MONEY WAS APPROVED.
UNDERSTOOD YOUR- EMAIL SAID O.
C. C. R. YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT THERE ARE MANY
OBSTACLES PUT IN PLACE THAT
BECAME MORE DIFFICULT- TO EVEN
REFER CASES TO THE ANCIENT OF
THE EXCLUSIONARY CRITERIA SOME
OF IT WAS CONCERNING- COUPLED
WITH. OTHER PROCESSES
UNDERSTAND THAT WE STILL HAVE
WARDENS FOR HIGHER THIRTIES
CONSERVE REFER CASES UP OVER
FOUR INVESTIGATION OUTSIDE OF
THE AIMS PROCESS AND WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY ANYWHERE FROM TWO
THOUSAND TO TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
OF THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN REFERRED FOR
INVESTIGATION WHICH WERE
RESULTING IN ADVERSE ACTIONS
ANYWHERE FROM TWELVE HUNDRED TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ADVERSE
ACTIONS. SO WARDENS DO- HAVE
THE ABILITY TO FOLLOW THIS
PROCESS I WAS RELEASED AIMS IT
WAS VERY DIFFICULT WHEN IT WAS
IN THE INFANCY- I DO AGREE
NEEDS TO BE FIXED IT NEEDS TO
BE FIXED NOW I PRIDE MYSELF ON
BEING A PERSON OF INTEGRITY AND
THIS DEPARTMENT IN A DEPARTMENT
OF INTEGRITY AND IN ORDER TO DO
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE STAFF
PROPERLY TRAINED YOU HAVE TO
HAVE AN INVESTIGATIVE INQUIRY
PROCESS. THAT IS THOROUGH AND
TRANSPARENT. I'M ANXIOUS TO GET
THERE AS- I WILL SAY THAT THE
CORRECTIONAL POLICY RESEARCH AN
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT UNIT WHO
TOOK OVER THE APPEAL- THE
APPEALS AND GRIEVANCE PROCESS.
IT IS IMPORTANT REYES. HAS
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO TRY AND
GET THIS RIGHT BUT IT'S NOT
RIGHT YOU MIGHT AS I SIT HERE
IN FRONT OF YOU IT IS NOT RIGHT
BUT I AM COMMITTED TO FIX AND
THAT'S A LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. YOUR STAFF
AND THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL GOING FORWARD- THE
THING. HOW. I'M USUALLY NOT A
LOSS FOR WORDS BUT TRULY AT A
COMPLETE LOSS OF WORDS I HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN SAYING. AT HOME. DID YOU
WATCH THE VIDEO AND WOULD YOU
AGREE THAT SECRETARY DíAS TO
HEAR FROM THIS CHAIR RIGHT HERE
A YEAR AGO- PROMISING TO HAVE A
COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT- PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE VIDEO CUT OUT
BUT I WAS IN THAT HEARING TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN MR DíAS SAID I
SAW- I RECALL EXACTLY WHAT HE
HAS SAID. AND IT THE PROCESS
DID GO OVER TO AN INDEPENDENT-
UNIT IT WAS NO LONGER IN THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
IS WHERE APPEALS PROCESS LAID
BEFORE. IT IS NOW AN OUTSIDE
UNIT THAT REPORTS TO THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF ADMIN NOT THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATIONS.
HOWEVER THE PROCESS AND THE
AIMS PROCESS. WAS TOO COMPLEX
TO. BUDGETARY CRITERIA FOR BUT
THAT WASN'T MY QUESTION SO.
THAT THE SECRETARY START HERE
SAID IN FRONT OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT HE- PROMISED
A COMPLETELY. INDEPENDENT
PROCESS WOULD YOU AGREE WITH
THAT. YES THEY GET YES OR NO
QUESTION SECRETARY. YES THAT IS
WHAT HE SAID I HOWEVER I DO
AGREE WITH THAT WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH THAT. FIGURE I DID NOT SEE
HIS WORDS IN REAL TIME TODAY. I
CAN NOT YOU SAID YOU WERE HERE
AT THE HEARING WOULD YOU AGREE
THAT YOU PROMISED THIS
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY EIGHT AND A
SEPARATE INDEPENDENT PROCESS.
THAT IS MY RECALL YES BURKE SO
WHO WHO UNDERNEATH HIM
UNDERMINED HIM AND DECIDED TO
NOT FOLLOW HIS INSTRUCTIONS.
WHO IN YOUR DEPARTMENT. I HAVE
NO IDEA ITWAS SET UP THROUGH A
SEPARATE ENTITY OUT OF THE
OPERATIONS UNIT BUT I WILL SAY
I'M I'M SITTING HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO COMMIT TO FIXING IT.
UP FIRST AND GOAL I HAVEN'T
HEARD A SINGLE THING ON HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO FIX IT FOR YOU
YOU DO YOU CAN OU TALK ABOUT
HOW THE PROCESS IS COMPLICATED
WE AGREED YOU INSERTED. THE
WARDENS INTO AN INDEPENDENT
PROCESS. SO YOU'RE RIGHT IT IS
COMPLICATED WHY WHY DID THE
DEPARTMENT COMPLICATE. THIS
RATHER SIMPLISTIC PROCESS BY
INSERTING THE WARDENS INTO THE
PROCESS. I CANNOT SPEAK FOR
PARTY LEADERSHIP WHAT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE PARDON FOR HOW
MANY YEARS NOW. YOU ACT LIKE
YOU ARE A NEW EMPLOYEE HOW MANY
YEARS HAVE BEEN AT THE TOP HAVE
YOU BEEN A PART. THERE I DON'T
WANT TO DEPARTMENT MANY YEARS
AS YOU NOW THIRTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR- SO YOU'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
PRIOR MINISTRATION. WHAT WAS
YOUR PREVIOUS JOB BEFORE THIS.
UNDER SECRETARY OF OPERATIONS
THIS THIS PROCESS DID NOT FALL
FALL UNDER THE OPERATIONS YOU
YOU ARE ON THIS IS
UNDERSECRETARY YOU'RE PART OF
THE LEADERSHIP TEAM. YES I WAS
AND I WAS SURPRISED AT ITS USE
ARGUE REMAIN AND YOU ARE AND
YOU CONTINUE TO BE. SO WHY DID
THE DEPARTMENT. SO YOU'RE
TELLING ME AS PART OF THE
SECRETARY LEADERSHIP TEAM YOU
HAVE NO IDEA WHO SEVERE SCHOOL
SUBVERTED HIS INTENTION TO HAVE
AN INDEPENDENT PROCESS. IN OUR
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE NAY
UNDER SECRETARY HAVE ADMIN.
REPORTS DIRECTLY TO THE
SECRETARY AND UNDERSECRETARY OF
OPERATIONS REPORTS DIRECTLY TO
THE SECRETARY. AND THAT OVER
TIME THE UNDERSECRETARY OF
ADMIN MADE THAT DECISION TO
SUBVERT THE INTENTION OF THE
SECRETARY. I DON'T KNOW WHO
MADE THAT DECISION SIR BUT THE
PERSON SOMEBODY IN DOT IN THAT
OPERATION YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MADE ALONG
THE WAY THAT CHANGED IT I THINK
THE EXCLUSIONARY CRITERIA AS
WELL AS HAVING THE WORK TO MAKE
THE DECISION THAT WE WHO MADE
THAT DECISION BECAUSE YOU SAID
YOU ARE SO COMMITTED TO FIXING
IT. HOW CAN YOU FIX THE PROBLEM
IF YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO MADE
THE DECISION. BECAUSE I PROVIDE
CLEAR DIRECTION. AND I WILL
HAVE CONSTANT OVERSIGHT OF THIS
PROBLEM WITH A LOT SECRETARY
SAID. I CANNOT SPEAK TO WHAT HE
SAID I CAN ONLY COUNT FOR
MYSELF WILL YOU LOOK WHAT
WORKED I WON'T LET MYSELF WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM. SANTA CRUZ A
THING THAT YOU HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NO CREDIBILITY RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T
DEMONSTRATED. YOU HAVE A GRASP
OF WHAT THE PROBLEM IS AND YOU
HAVEN'T TOLD US YOU SAID THE
WORD WE'RE GOING TO FIX THE
PROBLEM THE NUMBER TIMES YOU
HAVEN'T TOLD US HOW YOU CAN FIX
IT HOW YOU HOW YOU CAN FIX THE
PROBLEM. IF YOU CAN EVEN
IDENTIFY WHERE THE PROBLEM IS.
THE PROBLEM LIES WITH. ALL OF
THE ALLEGATIONS GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF THE LOCAL
INSTITUTION. EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF YOU DOING PERFECT. WE
UNDERSTAND THE- YEAH I DID THE
RESPECT GIVE ME THE RESPECT
FINISH. EVERY ALLEGATION WILL
BE IMMEDIATELY FORWARDED TO THE
OUTSIDE UNIT. OBJECTIVE AS SOON
AS MY FALCON FINISH THE
DOCUMENTATION ON THE MEMO OUT
TO STAFF THAT WILL IMMEDIATELY
TAKE PLACE AND THEY WILL NO
LONGER GO THROUGH SCREENING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. THAT IS THE
FIRST AND FOREMOST CORRECTION
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. SECONDLY
ALL USE OF FORCE ALLEGATIONS
WILL GO TO ALL USE OF FORCE
EXCESSIVE OR UNNECESSARY FORCE
WILL GO TO THE INCIDENT
IMMEDIATELY WORK WORD DRESSING
THE VERY SPECIFIC POINTS OF THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
THAT HE HIGHLIGHTED IN HIS
REPORT AS WELL AS OUR FINDINGS.
AS WELL AS PROVIDING CLEAR.
WHEN THE REPORT IS DONE TO BOOK
CLEAR CONCLUSION THE REPORTS
NOW JUST LIST ALL THE VARIOUS
INTERVIEWS OF WHAT EVERYBODY
SAID WITH NO FINAL
RECOMMENDATION NO DRAFTING OF
THE INVESTIGATION REQUEST
DOCUMENT WHICH IS CRITICAL IN
THIS PROCESS THOSE ARE THE TOP
THREE THINGS THAT WERE GOING TO
FIX IT IMMEDIATELY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT SO ON IS THE IS THERE
A REASON PRIOR TO COMING.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE YOU
ALREADY HAD A COPY OF THE
REPORT WHY THEY WEREN'T ALREADY
DONE AND DONE CENTER. I'M SORRY
SIR I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR QUESTION A BUBBLE ONCE
ONCE THE- OFF OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT WAS MADE- YOU
KNOW WAS WAS WAS GIVEN TO YOU
YOU YOU OBVIOUSLY HAD A RECORD
OF THIS- WHAT WHY WASN'T IT
DONE AS SOON AS YOU WERE MADE
AWARE OF THE ISSUE. HE. CHAPTER
IMMEDIATELY I CAN PROBABLY GIVE
YOU THE EXACT DAY WHERE I MET
WITH SOUTH AFTER READING THAT
REPORT I RECEIVED A REPORT A
FEW DAYS AHEAD OF THE FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH AND I'D ALREADY HAD A
MEETING AND WE'RE IDENTIFYING
VERY CRITICAL PIECES TO FIX AND
THOSE WITH THE TOP THREE THAT
WERE IMMEDIATELY IDENTIFIED
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO VOLUME WISE
HANDLE THE LOAD BECAUSE I HAVE
TO TRAIN STAFF THIS TRAINING
CRITICAL COMPONENT I HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STAFF
SCREENING THESE- ALLEGATION
CHOIRS ARE THOROUGHLY TRAINED
SO THAT THEY. CAN BE HANDLED IN
A PROPER MANNER. WHAT WILL YOU
WEAR OF THE ISSUE PRIOR TO THIS
GENERAL'S REPORT BEING RELEASED.
HE YES WE HAD SOME INDEPENDENT
REVIEWS GOING ON- THROUGH OUR-
COOKS CORRECTIONAL RESEARCH
CORRECTION POLICY RESEARCH AN
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT UNIT. WAS
DOING INDEPENDENT REVIEWS AND
DISCOVERED SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS AND THEY HAD ALREADY
RECOMMENDED. THAT WE CHANGE
SOME OF THE DEFINITIONS.
WARDENS I WILL SAY THAT THE
WARDENS WERE MADE THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE FOUND THAT THE WARDENS
WERE NOT APPROPRIATELY APPLYING
WHAT WE GAVE THEM WITHIN THE
PARAMETERS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE WITH THAT
DEFINITION THAT MAY LEAD TO
ADVERSE ACTION. WHAT WAS THE
NUMBER ONE AREA OF CONCERN- BUT
WE DIDN'T FIND WATER BORDERS
pWERE INTENTIONALLY NOT
FORWARDING CASES ON THAT IS NOT
WHAT WE FOUND IT WAS HONESTLY
THAT. THE PROCESS WAS TOO
COMPLICATED THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION SO
DEFINITELY LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A OUTSIDE SCREENER AND
THEN. GIVING THEM GOOD
INFORMATION AT THE VERY END.
FOR OUR INVESTIGATION PROCESS.
ALSO DO YOU THINK YOU'LL HOW
LONG THINK WILL TAKE THE TWO-
THE STAFF SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
AN- PROCESS THAT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED. I'M THIS IS WHAT
I'M GOING TO SAY BECAUSE I
THINK WE HAVE TO HIRE SOME
STAFF- AND GET THEM TRAINED SO.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS PROVIDE
YOU REGULAR UPDATES I WANT TO
SAY THIRTY TO SIXTY DAYS BUT
THE STATE HIRING PROCESSES
TAKES WHILE- IS AS WE ALL KNOW
BUT I WANT TO DEFINITELY WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF AND IF YOU WANT
TO SIGN A STAFF MEMBER TO WORK
WITH US ON OUR- OR RECEIVE
REGULAR BRIEFINGS YOURSELF. I'M
CERTAINLY WELCOME AND- TO DO
THAT. WELL LET'S JUST SAY BY
THE END OF MAY WHICH IS WHEN WE
FINISH OUR BUDGET DELIBERATION
PROCESS WE SHOULD HAVE A PRETTY
CLEAR IDEA OF. THE YOU KNOW HOW
THE- NEW PROCESSES IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED WHETHER WE WERE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT IS THAT FAIR.
STILL THERE SIR THANK YOU ARM
SO WE HEARD SECRETARY DíAS A
STATEMENT ARE YOU. COMMITTING
TO THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL TO
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT. A REVIEW
PROCESS. SO THE ALLEGATIONS
INQUIRES EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM WILL COME OUT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS AND GO TO A
CENTRALIZED SCREENING UNIT.
VERY COMMITTED TO MAKING THAT
HAPPEN- PROVIDING WHATEVER
NECESSARY DATA IN A BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE. ON OUR ALLEGATION
CHOIR IS COMPLETED AS WELL AS-
OUR INVESTIGATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN REFERRED. SOMETIMES EVEN
OUTSIDE OF AN ALLEGATION CHOIR
SOMETIMES WARDENS HAVE ENOUGH
TO FORWARD AND INCIDENTS- FOR
ADVERSE ACTION DIRECTLY OUTSIDE
OF THE ALLEGATION REQUIRED
PROCESS. THANK YOU HOW HOW LONG
DO YOU THINK IT'LL TAKE TO.
CREATE THE CENTRALIZED DATA
PROCESSING YOU YOU HAD
MENTIONED THAT OBVIOUSLY TAKES
TIME- THE STATE'S TRADITIONALLY
STRUGGLED WITH PUTTING
TOGETHER- DATABASES- I. T.
PROJECT I DON'T KNOW HOW BIG A
PROJECT THIS IS THE YOU
ENVISIONED HOW MUCH TIME DO YOU
THINK YOU IT WOULD TAKE TO COME
UP WITH A CENTRALIZED DATA
PROCESS. OUR SYSTEM. YES I
WOULD AGREE THAT'S PROBABLY THE
MOST COMPLEX- PROCESS AND- TO
BE ANY KIND OF ID PROCESS AND
SHE SAID I'VE BEEN AROUND A
LONG TIME- IT TAKES A LONG TIME
TO GET THAT DONE I
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO
HOPEFULLY HAVE SOMETHING UNDER
WAY WITH PLANNING OF DEPLOYMENT
BY THE END OF MAY OF. OUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT JUST
OCCUR IS THERE A WAY TO MAKE IT
JUST A SIMPLER. DATABASE I MEAN
I'M NOT RECOMMENDING LIKE.
EXCEL OR ACCESS BECAUSE THEY'RE
A WAY TO DO SOMETHING THAT'S
MORE. OFF THE SHELF AND HOW TO
DO SOMETHING THAT IS YOU KNOW.
PRETTY TIME INTENSIVE. NOT THE
BEST PERSON TO ANSWER THAT IS
I'M NOT A COMPUTER EXPERT BY
ANY MEANS- AND I MAYBE MISS
MILLER HAS HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ASSESS THE FLOOR FURTHER
THAN I HAVE- SO I'M GONNA AND
ASKING ME TO. PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION AND GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG- SO THE IT
THE CURRENT PROCESS FOR
TRACKING ALLEGATIONS THAT AN
INSTITUTION IS DONE ON A LOCAL
ALLOCATION LOG IN UP TO THIS
POINT IT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN A
PRETTY SIMPLE- SPREADSHEET IF
YOU WELL- THE UNFORTUNATE
REALITY IS YOU COULDN'T
ACTUALLY CROSS REFERENCE ANY
INFORMATION IT. IT DIDN'T HAVE
WHAT YOU NEEDED TO DO THAT- THE
OTHER COMPLICATED PIECE OF THIS
IS THAT WE ACTUALLY. KEEP
INFORMATION IN SEVERAL
DIFFERENT DATABASES. WITH THAT
SAID THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR ENTERPRISE
INFORMATION SYSTEMS AND OTHERS
HAVE GOTTEN TOGETHER AND
THEY'RE WORKING OUT AN I. T.
SOLUTIONS. IDEALLY IT WOULD
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ACTIVATED BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WITH CO THAT
RESOURCES WERE WORTH- MOVE
OTHER PLACES OVER THE LAST
YEAR- AND SO I ASK THIS
PANDEMIC. STARTS TO TWO THINGS
START TO GET BETTER- THE
SECRETARY HAS COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE RESOURCES
ARE AVAILABLE TO GET THAT I. T.
SOLUTION IN PLACE AND SO-
ALREADY THERE'S ACTIVITY ON
MAKING SURE THAT THE DIFFERENT
DATA. SYSTEMS TALK TO EACH
OTHER AND IF THERE IS A
BEGINNING TO END FROM EVERY
ALLEGATION THAT'S EVER MADE ALL
THE WAY TO WHAT HAPPENED AS THE
CAN. AND RIGHT NOW THE
EXPECTATION IS END OF MAY FOR
HAVING THAT. HOPEFULLY DEPLOYED
OKAY PERFECT MY NAME ONLY CAME
TO SEE ME AS I HOPE WE DON'T
LET THE PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF
THE GOOD AND- WOULD RATHER
HAVE. SOMETHING SIMPLER WITH
SOME DATA THAN LIKE THE PERFECT
SYSTEM THAT TAKES FOREVER
SOURCE APPRECIATE THAT. JUST
ONE ONE FINAL COMMENT LET ME
JUST. DOUBLE THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S HERE LET ME JUST. ON
THANK FOR HIS. REPORT I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO. SAY I THINK. THAT
YOUR WORK OVER THE LAST NUMBER
OF YEARS HAS REALLY. HELPED
INFORM THIS COMMITTEE A LOT OF
THE WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING- I PERSONALLY JUST WANT
TO SAY HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE.
THE ANALYSIS THAT THE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND FRIEND
FRANKLY. IN MY OPINION THE
OBJECTIVITY THAT- THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL BRINGS. IT'S NOT I
DON'T FIND HIS REPORTS TO BE A
GOTCHA REPORT BUT TO BE ON THE
VERY OBJECTIVE AND VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD SO I JUST WANT
TO THANK HIM AND HIS TEAM FOR
ALL THEIR FATHER HARPER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL- SO. WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA NINETY
SOLUTION AND HOPE THAT WE SEE
SOMETHING COME THE END OF MAY-
MAKING DECISIONS BUT WHAT ARE
YOU SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU THINK THAT DEPARTMENT CANBE DOING STARTING TOMORROW
BEFORE MADE AT THE COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED TO CREATE A BETTER
SYSTEM WHAT CAN WHAT ARE
IMMEDIATE THINGS WE COULD DO
NOW IN YOUR- IN YOUR OPINION
HERE. WELL I THINK THE
SECRETARY ADDRESSED SOME OF
THOSE THINGS- AGAIN WE HAD A
DISCUSSION LAST WEEK- GETTING
THE INSTITUTIONS OUT OF THE
PROCESS. IS A BIG PART OF THAT-
ELIMINATING THE OFF RAMPS FOR-
INCREASE TO BE DUMPED AND OF
SETTING UP A PROCESS WHERE-
REPORTS CAN BE RUN AND DATA CAN
BE CAPTURED TO ASSESS HOW THE
PROGRAM IS WORKING ARE HUGE
STEPS AND I THINK THOSE ARE-
PROBABLY THE MAJOR THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE. IT CAN I MEAN
CAN ALL THESE COMPLAINTS JUST
BE SENT DIRECTLY TO AIMS NOW. I
AYE SINGLE IMPEDIMENT TO THAT
THE THERE HAS TO BE A PLACE
THAT AIMS FOR THEM TO GO. BUT I
THINK THAT- THE DEPARTMENT HAS
A VERY GOOD MODEL IN ITS- IN
ITS- OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
FOR HAVING A CENTRAL- REVIEW OF
ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT. SO I
DON'T SEE ANY REASON WHY CAN'T
OTHER THAN- ASSIGNING THE
DUTIES. HOW LONG WOULD IT TAKE
YOU TO FIND THOSE DUTIES. BEEN
CHAIR KATHLEEN ALEX SAID- I
WOULD LIKE TO COMMIT TO HAVING
A MEMO OUT WITHIN A WEEK
BECAUSE CENTRALIZED MAILBOX FOR
THE INSTITUTION STAFF TO BE
ABLE TO SEND THOSE- COMPLAINTS
TO. AND SO MY STAFF USUALLY
RIDING BECAUSE THIS IS- I KNOW
THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON THE
MEMO ALL AND HOW IT'S GOING TO
WORK IN A PROCESS BUT WE'RE
GONNA PUT SOME PARAMETERS
AROUND THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT HAPPENS WE WILL FORWARD YOU
A COPY. OF ONCE THAT IS
COMPLETED VIA- YOUR BABY. IF
GREAT ABOUT A WEEK WILL ABLE TO
THAT BEFORE THE IMPLEMENTATION
BEGAN TH YES MA'AM AND THAT'S
BEEN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
BEEN BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
THAT AT IN THE PAST- THE
COMMITTEE WAS NOT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW ANY NEW
REGULATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
USED TO IMPLEMENT- THIS PROCESS
AND SO- I HEARD EARLIER THAT
YOU ARE OPEN TO BOTH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL BUT ALSO THIS
COMMITTEE BEGINNING GATES IN
THAT PROCESS. ABSOLUTELY AND SO
WE DEFINITELY WANT TO TAKE YOU
UP. ON THAT- S. AS WELL- I
GUESS YOU KNOW I LIKE TO THINK
ABOUT IT WE HAVE THE AND THE
MAY DEADLINE AND THAT'S AN
ACTUAL DEADLINE I THINK AS
YOU'RE TRYING TO REBUILD TRUST
WITH THE COMMUTE WITH THE
COMMITTEE- GIVEN THAT. THERE'S
JUST NOT TRUST. AYE AND
RIGHTFULLY SO WHAT ARE SOME
STEPS. OR SOME ADDITIONAL MEMOS
CORRESPOND THANK YOU SHARE WITH
US ALONG THE WAY SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO WAIT. BETWEEN ONE WEEK
FROM THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE FIRST MEMO AND THEN MAKE
WHAT IS THAT YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
SOME BENCHMARKS THAT WE CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO. WELL I WOULD
LIKE TO SET UP REGULAR CADENCE
MEETINGS OR BRIEFINGS WITH YOU
WHATEVER. WORKS BEST FOR YOU-
AND THE COMMITTEE WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW BRIEFING YOUR STAFF ON
A REGULAR CADENCE WHETHER WE
SEND YOU A WEEKLY DOCUMENT OUR
PROGRESS- WHATEVER YOU THINK
WILL WORK BEST FOR YOU TO. KEEP
BE REGULARLY INFORMED. I'D LIKE
TO. PROVIDE YOU WITH VARIETY
WHAT- THE INITIAL STEPS THAT
WE'RE DOING. AND THEN OPEN
CONVERSATION FOR THE SUBSEQUENT
STEPS THAT I THINK- NEED TO BE
EVALUATED BUT YOU NEED SOME
TIME. I DEFINITELY WANT TO GET
THIS THING RIGHT I. YEAH HOW DO
I SAY THIS DON'T I RATHER I
DON'T WANT TO RUSH IT I WANT TO
GET IT RIGHT THIS TIME AND I
CERTAINLY WELCOME- OF THE INPUT
HAVE YOU AND YOUR STAFF. ALONG
YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM THIS
PROCESS- OKAY SO. WE DON'T WANT
ONE I WANNA GO BACK TO MR
THINGS COMMON THAT WE DON'T
WANT THE PERFECT TO BE THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD AND SO WHILE
WE DON'T WANT TO RUSH SOMETHING
I DON'T WANT THINGS LIKE IT
SOLUTIONS OR A PROCESS TO THE
LATEST MUCH FURTHER- IF YOU'RE
ASKING HAS COME JUNE THAT WE
HAVE TO VOTE ON SOMETHING AND
WE HAVE NO CONFIDENCE THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A VERY GOOD.
RESOLUTION OUT THERE INTO
DEFINITELY WANT TO TAKE YOU UP
ON THOSE REGULAR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE SO WE COULD
BE SAYING THAT WITH OUR MEMBERS
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
ADDITION TO MEMBERS THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO SEE ANY NEW REGULATIONS
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED REFORMS
LIMITATION. US WE COULD ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT IT MAKES SENSE
TO US AND IT'S NOT OVERLY
COMPLICATED. I'M AND THEN. JUST
TO BE CLEAR WE ARE GOING TO
RETWEET WE USE THE WORDS BEEN
AND THAT CONFUSES ME AT TIMES
TO BE KERRIGAN EVERY REMOVING
AWARD IS WHEN THIS PROCESS- AND
WE NEED TO THE WAIT STAFF.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT THAT
THAT AIM SEPARATE FROM STAFF AT.
THE PRESENCE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR ASKING FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION. YES ALL
ALLEGATION CHOIR REESE WILL GO
FROM THERE. IL'S OFFICE PICKS
THEM UP FROM THE VARIOUS YARDS
AT THE INSTITUTION. THEY WILL
BE MAILED DIRECTLY TO AIMS OR
INTO A EMAIL BOX FOR GAINES.
RIGHT CLICK AND THEN AIMS WILL
SCREEN THEM FOR A FINAL
DETERMINATION ON WHAT TO DO%
WITH THAT ALLEGATION EQUERRY.
SO GIVEN THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
SENDING STUFF DIRECTLY TO AIMS-
AND THEY ARE GOING FROM HAVING.
FIVE HUNDRED OR SO CLAIMS THAT
THEY WERE GETTING ALL FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY CLAIMS I
APOLOGIZE. I THE FIFTH
INSPECTOR GENERAL IF AIMS IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL- WITH EVERYTHING
COMING DIRECTLY TO THEM OR
THEIR ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT.
THAT WE AT THE LEGISLATURE NEED
TO BE AWARE OF TO ENSURE THAT
THIS IS- THAT THIS SUCCESSFUL
LAWYER AND INDEED THANK. YOU
HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE INCREASING
CASELOAD- ABOUT CITY. WELL OUR
PLAN IS TO REDIRECT RESOURCES
INITIALLY WE DO HAVE A TIME AND
MOTION STUDY GOING ON RIGHT NOW
AS WE- ENTER THIS NEW PROCESS-
I WILL SAY KOBE HAS TAUGHT US A
LOT AS FAR AS EFFICIENCIES AND
THE UTILIZATION. OF THE VIDEO
CAPABILITY WE LOSE A LOT OF
TIME TRAVELING. TO
INSTITUTIONAL INSTITUTION AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING GREATER
EFFICIENCIES THROUGH TECHNOLOGY.
CAN I GIVE MY QUESTION WAS FOR
THEIR- THE INSPECTOR GENERAL DO
YOU FEEL THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES THAT AIMS YOUR
OPINION GIVEN TO REVIEW YOUR
PARTICULARLY. THE ONLY COMMENT
I COULD MAKE TO THAT IS THAT-
AT THE MOMENT THEY DO NOT
APPEAR TO BE WORKING AT THE
CAPACITY. WHETHER THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES I DON'T
THINK YOU KNOW UNTIL YOU GET TO
YOUR CAPACITY AND SEE WHAT
THEIR WORKLOAD IS. SO I DON'T I
CAN'T REALLY COMMENT ON WHETHER
THEY HAVE ENOUGH I CAN ONLY
TELL YOU THAT. THEY DON'T
APPEAR TO BE WORKING AT
CAPACITY. DO YOU HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF WHAT CAPACITY MIGHT
BE. WELL THE ONLY DATA THAT I
HAVE IS WHAT THEY PUT FORWARD
IN THEIR B. C. P. HERE TWO
YEARS AGO. OR A YEAR AGO- SO-
AT THE TIME THEY INDICATED THAT
THEY COULD DO FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR BELIEVE- FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR COMPLAINTS
A MONTH- INCREASE PER MONTH.
AND THAT WAS- A LITTLE OVER
ALMOST FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED.
INCREASE PER YEAR- THEY'RE NOT
THERE YET SO- THAT'S THE DATA I
HAVE I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THEIR- DATA IS ACCURATE- AND
AGAIN I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU CAN.
YOU CAN DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S
ACCURATE UNTIL YOU'RE AT
CAPACITY AND SEE WHAT IT IS YOU
CAN'T GET. ARE YOU ARE YOU ABLE
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THIS
NEW PROCESS. OUR OVERSIGHT IS
EXTREMELY LIMITED- I HAVE FIVE
PEOPLE FOR THE ENTIRE STATE-
AND THE- AS AS YOU. AS I
PREDICT THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS IS- MUCH MUCH MORE
THAN FIVE PEOPLE CAN CAN
MONITOR EVEN IF WE MONITOR ONLY
A PORTION OF THOSE. I FEEL-
SOUL I WOULD TELL YOU THAT I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT- I. G. AS
RESOURCE ADEQUATELY TO PROVIDE.
A REASONABLE OVERSIGHT. OKAY
HERE. WHEN A CUSTOMER ORDERS IF
THEY'RE LUCKY. YES THANK YOU
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO. THANK
MISTER WESLEY FOR RESPONDING TO
MY- MY QUESTION BACK IN
FEBRUARY EIGHTH AND SENT ME A
WRITTEN RESPONSE ABOUT MY- MY
QUESTION YOU ARE UNABLE TO
ANSWER. ABOUT SEGWIT NOT VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE FOLLOW UP
DOESN'T HAPPEN ALL THE TIME- I
JUST HAPPEN TO HAVE. SO THE
UNIQUE TO THIS COMMITTEE IN
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF A- ACTUALLY
CONDUCTING. POTENTIAL
APPOINTMENTS CONDUCTIVITY
GEISHAS AND I WORK FOR A STATE
AGENCY THAT HAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT DYNAMIC BUT- TAKES
GREAT PRIDE AND FALLS UNDER A
LITTLE DIFFERENT. SET OF LAWS
THAT DICTATE HOW DO. CONDUCT
THESE INVESTIGATIONS- FIRST OF
ALL I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
PROCEDURALLY FIRST OF ALL IT
SEEMS LIKE. SOME OF THIS
PROCESS WOULD BE NEGOTIATED
THROUGH LABOR. CONCERNS OF MY
RIGHT ON THAT. THE PROCESS ON
HOW TO ADDRESS- A APPOINTMENTS
CONDUCT IS THAT SOMEONE
NEGOTIATED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT
LUCKY THIS IS AMY MILLER AND
YES YOU WOULD BE CORRECT THAT
THAT INDEED SOME OF THIS FALLS
INTO LABOR AGREEMENTS. YES I
JUST WONDER HOW MUCH AUTHORITY
YOU CAN. A SPEAK TO ON
IMPROVEMENTS IN AND WAYS TO
ADDRESS THIS PROCESS I WOULD
THINK THAT. THERE ARE OTHER
PARTIES THAT MIGHT BE INVOLVED
IN THIS KIND OF A- PROCESS AND
I'M I'M CURIOUS ABOUT WE TALK
ABOUT ALLEGATION IN CORY'S AND-
AND I'M SURE THAT THAT'S A
SCREENING PROCESS JUST BECAUSE
OF THE SHEER VOLUME OF.
POTENTIAL OF MISCONDUCT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT YOU ADDRESS
BUT WHAT IS THE STANDARD BY
WHICH IT MOVES FROM. THAT
INQUIRY TO AN ACTUAL
INVESTIGATION IS A
PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE OR IS
IT IS A GREATER THAN THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION ACTUALLY
WE WORK WITH- THE STANDARD OF
REASONABLE BELIEF. THAT TO MOVE
AN INQUIRY INTO AN
INVESTIGATION AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT A PRUDENT
PERSON RELIES ON IN ADDITION TO
THEIR TRAINING EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE TO
FORMULATE A GOOD FAITH BELIEF.
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL HAS
CONDUCTED THE MISCONDUCT SO.
WHERE A HIGH ARE WHERE AN
ALLEGATION WITHOUT EVIDENCE
DEFINITELY. WOULDN'T GO INTO
OUR INQUIRY- THOUGHT PROCESS
ONCE WE REACH THAT REASONABLE
BELIEF STANDARD- IT WOULD THEN.
GO. INTO AN INVESTIGATION
PROCESS. OKAY WILL PLAY YOU FOR
THAT LAST YEAR- YEAH I THINK IT
WAS LAST YEAR MAYBE TWO YEARS
AGO THIS COMMITTEE EXPRESSES
CONCERN THAT SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
AND HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS WERE
NOT ELEVATED TO AIMS. AND CAN
HELP US UNDERSTAND OF THE- WHY
THOSE MANY OTHER SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE ARE NOT
REFERRED TO IN THE AIMS-
NUMBERS AND ALL THOSE
ALLEGATIONS WERE HANDLED. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT LACKEY SO
THE- ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND STAFF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PROCESS BECAUSE
CDCR HAS IMPLEMENTED A PROCESS
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
FEDERAL STANDARDS FOR THE
PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION ACT.
AND IN THAT THERE'S PART OF
THAT THAT REQUIRES AN IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE SO THAT YOU CAN
COLLECT ANY EVIDENCE OF THAT
INCLUDES TAKING SOMEBODY OUT TO
A HOSPITAL FOR A SEXUAL ASSAULT
EXAM IF THE EVIDENCE. IF IT
HAPPENED RECENTLY AS WELL AS
GATHERING EVIDENCE THAT MIGHT
EXIST MAYBE IN A HOUSING UNIT
OR SOME OTHER LOCATION AND SO
THAT REQUIRES AN IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE AND RECOGNIZING THAT
ARE AIMS PROCESS IF YOU WILL IS
REGIONAL LIES WE WOULDN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GET THOSE
PERSONS TO THE INSTITUTION AND
THE TIME WE NEED. IN ORDER TO
DO THAT EVIDENCE GATHERING AND
GET THAT THE- INCARCERATED
PERSONS AS WELL AS IN SOME
CASES THE STAFF OUT FOR THESE
MEDICAL EXAMINATIONS AND
EVIDENCE COLLECTION. SO THE
THING YOU SEE OUR HOUSE PUT A
VERY THOUGHTFUL PROCESS. FOR
THE PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION ACT
INTO- THE EXISTING INSTITUTES
ARE INTO THE INSTITUTIONS AND
THAT INCLUDES VERY SPECIALIZED
TRAINING FOR PERSONS INVOLVED
IN THAT PROCESS FROM EVERYTHING
FROM EVIDENCE COLLECTION INTO
DOING THE INQUIRY'S- WE DO.
GROW AND AUDITING THAT IS AT
THE HIGH FEDERAL FEDERALLY
CERTIFIED AUDITORS EVERY THREE
YEARS AND SO THIS EXISTING
PROCESS HAS GONE THROUGH- THE
FEDERAL- PROCESS OF AUDITING
AND HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE. AND SO INSTEAD OF
RISKING- SPLITTING UP THAT
PROCESS AND RISKING HAVING A
SYSTEM THAT IS FEDERALLY
COMPLIANT THE DECISION WAS MADE
TO GO AHEAD AND EXCLUDE THOSE
OUT AT THE BEGINNING AND
CONTINUE WITH THE PROCESS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE. ANY QUESTION.
ON THE- I. G. MONITOR TEACHERS
ARE FREE OF. IN REAL TIME. OKAY
SO WHAT WE- UNDERSTAND THIS
EVER WORRY ALLEGATION FROM
BEING TO A- WHAT IS THE REVIEW.
OR OTHER PASS FOR THE L. TO BE
VIEW. SO IN THE PROCESS THAT
EXISTS RIGHT NOW IF THE BOARD
DECIDES THAT IT IT DOES NOT
MEET THE CRITERIA FOR AIMS AND
SO. IN THAT RESPECT IT WOULD
MEAN THA THE WARDEN HAS
DECIDED THAT IF TRUE ADVERSE
ACTION IS NOT LIKELY THAT IT
WOULD STAY WITHIN THE INTERNAL
PROCESS AT THE INSTITUTION AND
WOOD AND THE INCREASE WOULD BE
COMPLETED BY SUPERVISORS AT THE
INSTITUTION WHO HAVE BEEN
TRAINED BY THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS TO COMPLETE
THOSE ENQUIRIES. SONY COREY
STILL HAPPENS IT JUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN AT THIS EXTRA UNITS.
OKAY YES THIS IS BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK HER RESPONSE WAS
PRETTY SPECIFIC OKAY. I WANT I
WANT SORRY NO GO AHEAD. OKAY
AND THEN FOR THE RISON RAPE
ELIMINATION ACT AND FOR THOSE
INCREASED AGAIN THOSE STATE
INTERNALLY AND THOSE ENQUIRIES
ARE COMPLETED BY STAFF WHO HAVE
TRAINING BEYOND EVEN AN-
INQUIRY PROCESS PROVIDED BY THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INSTEAD IT'S TRAINING THAT'S
PUT TOGETHER AND PROVIDED TO
YOU. STAFF TO DO SPECIFIC
PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION IN
CORY'S- IT'S THE TRAININGS THAT
TRAINING IS ACTUALLY PROVIDED
BY OUR PRE YEAH ORDINATOR FOR
THE STATE. OKAY FINALLY WE HAVE
A LIST OF HOW MANY ALLEGATIONS
WERE SAID TO AIMS OF THE FIGURE
I HAVE BEFORE ME IS FIVE
HUNDRED ONLY FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
ONE. SO CAN WE IS IT POSSIBLE
TO HAVE A BREAKDOWN OF HOW MANY
REFER TO FROM WHICH PRISONS.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
POSSIBLE WE MAY HAVE SOME
INSTITUTIONS THAT AREN'T
SENDING ALLEGATIONS. OR IS IT
TOO COMPLEX AS YOU INDICATED. I
KNOW IT'S NOT TOO COMPLEX WE DO
HAVE THAT DATA THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE EVALUATED
FAIRLY. EARLY ON AND HAVE
IDENTIFIED CONCERNS AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING I WILL SAY
GOING FORWARD EVERY ALLEGATION
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE AIMS
UNIT. ROTH. THANK YOU- CAN I
RETURN TO THE O. I. G. AGAIN
YOU LET US KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
ONLY FIVE STAFF MEMBERS FOR
THIS OVERSIGHT- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS- RECOMMENDING
THAT YOU GUYS HAD TO ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT AND THAT WE HELP ARE
YOU ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
MONIES OF US TO HELP YOU BE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION THAT STAFF. HAS
MADE. WE WOULD NEED EXTRA WE
WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
THE- WE WOULD HAVE TO HIRE
STAFF TO DO THE OVERSIGHT THAT-
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION HERE IS
THAT DO YOU OVERSEE AT LEAST
25% OF STAFF EVEN SET ASIDE
ENOUGH I PROBLEMS WITH
COMPLIANCE. IN A THAT THEN THE
PRICE OF THE COIN CORRECTIVE
ACTION DO YOU HAVE AN
APPROXIMATE NUMBER OF HOW MUCH
THAT YOU NEED- WITH WITH A
FUNDING LEVEL MY LOOK LIKE.
FIVE WE'VE WORKED THAT UP- BUT
I DON'T HAVE IT. AT HAND THAT
CAN PROVIDE THAT TO YOU-
PROBABLY TOMORROW. THANK YOU
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL AND
THEN I HANDED OVER TO MR JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IN EVERYONE THAT- ST ONTO HIS
HEARING AND ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT MAY TIME OF FOR
THIS TODAY- I HAVE A- A
RECOMMENDATION THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE. BUT FIRST FORCE
FIRST SECRETARY- CATHLEEN
ALLISON- A DIFFERENT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT. THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED FROM WHEN YOU STARTED-
MANY MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE
NOW HAVE TWELVE YEARS. IN THE
PAST WHEN ALL THIS STARTED WE
WOULD BE GONE. AND THE
FRUSTRATION THAT YOU'RE FREE
FEELING RIGHT NOW. IS THAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR THINGS TWELVE
YEARS AGO SIX YEARS AGO OR TWO
YEARS AGO AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR
YOU. YOUR PREDECESSOR. AS LEFT
US WITH A HUGE CREDIBILITY GAP
WHICH NOW FALLS ON ON YOU AND
SO HOPEFULLY YOU FEEL THEIR
FRUSTRATION. WITH IN IN WITH
THIS COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW IN
BEING ABLE TO GET ANSWERS BUT
MOST IMPORTANT BEING ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD. YOU DON'T SEE A
LOT WE'RE BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS. ARE KINDA UNITED
IN FIXING THIS PROBLEM- AND
WHEN THE BUDGET CHAIR ASK YOU
WHO MAY HAVE UNDERMINED THE
FORMER SECRETARY. WHEN I WAS IN
YOUR OFFICE AND VISITING WITH
YOU AND TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO I REMEMBER ASKING
YOU WITH ANYBODY ELSE
LISTENING. AND YOU LOOKED AT ME
LIKE WHAT DO YOU MEAN NOT
BECAUSE I REALLY FELT. THAT THE
HELP OF CDCR MAY PUT OUT AN
EDICT. AND I USED TO WORK IN
BUREAUCRACIES BUT TO GET
UNDERMINE. AT THE LOWER LEVELS
AND SO THAT IS A VERY. VERY
REAL AND SERIOUS THING AND SO I
THE YOU GET UNDERMINE. FOUR
YOU'RE MISREPRESENTING TO THIS
COMMITTEE WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON AND SO I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON A BRACING THIS
IDEA OF HAVING CAMERAS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY OF OUR
CORRECTION SYSTEMS. HOW WE ARE
UTILIZING THE MINUTE FUND AND
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF NOT
ONLY OUR INCARCERATED
POPULATION BUT ALSO THE STAFF
HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY PREVALENT
AS A RESULT OF THE ONGOING
HEALTH PANDEMIC BUT WHILE WE
ARE HIGHLIGHTING SPECIFIC
INCIDENTS TODAY DISCUSSING THE
SHORTFALL THE CDC ARE IS
NOTHING NEW AND IS A TOPIC WE
EVERY VISIT IT YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR. A LOT OF
THE MOST RECENT- IG REPORT ON
THE STAFF MISCONDUCT PROCESS
ANNIE ARMSTRONG FISCALLY COURT
PROCEEDINGS IT IS CLEAR WE NEED
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO BRING ABOUT
MORE CONTABILIDADE TO OUR
CORRECTION SYSTEM. TODAY WE
WERE WE HEARD FROM THE L. I. G.
OF THEIR FINDINGS REGARDING THE
STAFF MISCONDUCT BUT I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THEIR DISCIPLINE
MONITORING REPORT FROM THIS
PAST YEAR. SPECIFICALLY THE
REPORT NOTED INCIDENTS IN WHICH
CDCR SETTLE CASES DESPITE THE
O. I. G.'S RECOMMENDATION OF A
HIGHER PENALTY OUTSTANDING
DELAYS A DISCIPLINARY ACTION
AND INVESTIGATIONS AND IN MOST.
AND ALMOST HALF OF THE CASES
MONITORED THE DEPARTMENT
ATTORNEYS DID NOT INSURE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION COMPLY WITH
THAT OUR POLICY IS ENTIRELY
UNACCEPTABLE. THAT AN ALREADY
LIMITED BUDGET CDCR HAS WAITED
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN JUST SIX
MONTHS BECAUSE OF DELAY
DISCIPLINE. BUT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT WE SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO GET
AWAY WITH GROSS ATTACKS ON
VULNERABLE INCARCERATED
POPULATIONS THEREFORE UNTIL WE
PRIOR TO RISE THE FUNDING OF AN
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT ENTITY
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO HOLD CDC
ARE COBBLES THESE ABUSES WILL
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN. WHILE WE
WERE MAYBE HIGHLIGHT THE STAFF
MAKAN PROCESS TODAY. MEMBERS
ALSO HAVING. HANDLING
DISCIPLINE IN CASES WHERE
FINDINGS ARE SUSTAINED AS WELL.
IS FOR THESE REASONS. THAT I
SUBMITTED A BUDGET REQUEST OF
ELEVEN ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO A QUICK THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL WITH THE
FUNDS THEY NEED TO CARRY OUT
THE VERY OVERSIGHT THEY WERE
COURAGEOUS. FOUR I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING THE CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE ALREADY HAD WHAT WILL
CONTINUE AT ABOUT GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING.
HI THE- THANK YOU- I HAVE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS- I'M ABOUT TO
CLOSE UP THIS PANEL I WHICH IS
SAFE FOR THE DEPARTMENT- I'M
GONNA TAKE YOUR BY YOUR OFFER
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH YOU AND
FOR YOU TO WORK WITH THE- ID TO
MAKE SURE WE COULD HAVE. SOME
SORT OF MOVEMENT BEFORE. MAYES
OVER- IT'S FRUSTRATING TO HEAR
INVESTMENT OF DOLLARS WHEN
THEY'RE STILL SCARES AND HAVE A
GOAL OF HAVING GOING LOWER-
IT'S FRUSTRATING AND IT'S
EMBARRASSING MORE THAN ANYTHING
AT THE END THE DAY WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE STAFF WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
INMATES TO TREAT THEM WITH
DIGNITY RESPECT TO MAKE SURE
THAT BOTH ARE BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND IT'S
EMBARRASSING WHEN WE HAVE
TELETEXT THERE'S THAT ONCE
AGAIN WE HAVE FAILED THEM- AND
WE HAVE FILLED IN THE WAY WE
USE OUR DOLLARS SINCE I HOPE.
THAT WE COULD QUICKLY WORKED
COLLABORATIVELY AS A TEAM AS
UNIT TO CORRECT THIS- SO THAT
WE CAN START TO TAKE A LITTLE
BIT OF PRIDE IN WHAT AND THIS
ADDITION THAT WE HAVE OUT HERE
AND SO I DO WANNA THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME I NOW IN IN YOUR
YOUR TIME THEN THERE WOULD HAVE
TO WORK ON. THIS I'M GONNA MOVE
ON TO OUR- SECOND. THE
PANELISTS FOR ISSUE TWO WILL
EACH PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF EACH OF THOSE THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE STATE YOUR NAME I AND
YOU CAN BEGAN I WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS AFTER
THE PANEL COVERS ALL THE
PROPOSAL FOR. PANELIST MAY
BEGIN SPEAKING IN THE ORDER
LISTED IN THAT AGENDA. LET'S
BEGIN. HERE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE YES.
OKAY I MEAN RATE DOWN THE NILE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. COURSE
BEFORE YOU INCLUDES FIFTY NINE
POSITIONS AND FUNDING OF ONE
TIME COST OF SIXTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS SPREAD
OVER THREE FISCAL YEARS AND%
ONGOING FUNDING OF SIXTEEN
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE FUNDING
WILL SUPPORT ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE BASIC CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
TRAINING FOR CADETS AND NEW
OFFICERS. ENTERING CDC OURS AT
ALL INSTITUTIONS. THE FUNDING
WILL ALSO SUPPORT STAFFING FOR
DEPOSED AS THE TRAINING
OVERSIGHT BODY FOR THIS
DEPARTMENT. WHILE CDC ARE
CURRENTLY REPORTS NEW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS A TIME
INTENSIVE BASIC ECONOMY THE
PHYSICAL LOCATION LOGISTICS
ASSOCIATED RESOURCES CURRENTLY
LIMIT THE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY
TO DELIVER DYNAMIC AND
SITUATIONALLY APPROPRIATE
TRAINING. THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND MODE OF
DELIVERY OF TRAINING FOR THIS
PROFESSION HAS NOT KEPT PACE
WITH THE DEMANDS AN ESSENTIAL
FUNCTIONS OF THIS JOB. THE
DEGREE OF ETHICAL DECISION
MAKING AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATION IS SUCH THAT OUR-OFFICERS MUST BE TRAINED USING
PROBLEM BASED TRAINING
SCENARIOS AND HANDS ON
APPLICATION WITHIN THE PRISON
ENVIRONMENT. HISTORICALLY NEW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS FILL SOME
OF THE MOST HIGH RISK POST DUE
TO THE POSTED BEEN PROCESS
WHERE SENIOR OFFICERS TEND TO
FORGO SOME OF THESE POSTS THAT
MAY HAVE A HIGHER RATE OF STAFF
INJURY. IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
THE DEPARTMENT TO PREPARE STAFF
BEFORE THEIR FIRST ASSIGNMENT
IN THIS CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT. THE THREE PRONGED
APPROACH IN THIS PROPOSAL
SERVICE TO CLOSE THE GAP BY.
CONVERTING THE FORMER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY
INTO AN ADVANCED DEPARTMENTAL
TRAINING FACILITY TO PROVIDE
NEW CADETS WITH CRITICAL
REALITY BASED TRAINING.
IMPLEMENTING A FOUR WEEK JOB
SHADOWING PROGRAM UNDER THE
OVERSIGHTOF THE FIELD TRAINING
CORRECTIONAL SERGEANT. AND
STAFFING SUPPOSED TO FULLY MEET
THE LEGAL MANDATE OF AUDITING
AND EVALUATING CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICER TRAINING
INCLUDING SUPERVISORY AND
LEADERSHIP ROLES. AS FORMATIVE
CHANGES EMPHASIZE. MENTORING HM
AND STAFF COMP. WHICH THE A
COLD SHIFT WITHIN OUR INDUSTRY.
I WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO
SARAH LARSON WHO WILL TALK
ABOUT OUR TECHNOLOGY FOR
INMATES PARTICIPATING IN
ACADEMIC PROGRAM PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM
RATE I'M NOT SURE CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK. YES GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M SEVERAL ARSON I'M
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AT THE START AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED I'M HERE TO
DISCUSS A LAPTOP PROPOSAL THAT
WE HAVE AND THE PROPOSAL
REQUEST APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND FORTY
THREE POSITIONS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND THIRTY EIGHT
POSSESSION. HERE'S AND ONGOING.
INDUSTRY WOULD PROVIDE LAPTOPS
ALL OF THE STUDENTS IN OUR DEAR
PETE ARE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
PROGRAMMING. AND THAT INCLUDES
OUR ACADEMIC EDUCATION LIKE
LETTERS E. AND G. DEEP PROGRAMS
WELL THEIR COLLEGE PROGRAMS.
INCLUDE DARKER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS OF STUDENTS-
UNDERGOING JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS THE BULLETS AT
STUDENTS. HER THE PEOPLE AND.
HEARING AGENDA NOTES NEARLY
FOUR NUMBER STOOD LACK THIRTY
OR HIGH SCHOOL. AND MORE THAN
FORTY SIX THOUSAND OF OUR
STUDENTS NOT GET RID OF THE
NINTH GRADE LEVEL IN ADDITION
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS LACK BASIC
COMPUTER LITERACY SKILLS WHICH
HAVE BECOME A BASIC.
PREREQUISITE TO MANY JOBS TODAY.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD USE LAPTOPS
TO SUPPORT IN CLASSROOM
LEARNING WOULD HELP EXTEND
LEARNING OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM AND WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY COMPUTER
SKILLS. IN THE CLASSROOM OUR
STUDENTS WOULD BE ABLE TO USE
THE DEVICES TO FOCUS ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND TO
PROGRESS AND PRACTICE THEIR
SKILLS AT THEIR OWN PACE. THEY
WERE THEN ABLE TO KEEP THOSE
DEVICES BACK TO THEIR HOUSING
UNITS FOR WHERE THEY LIVE AND
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE THEIR
SKILLS AND BUILD ON THAT
LEARNING THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
IN THE CLASSROOM. I'LL BE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THAT
YOU HAVE ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF
THE PROPOSAL. BUT FOR NOW I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO SHOP AROUND WHO
WILL INTRODUCE OUR COULD
NINETEEN WORKERS COMPENSATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HI THIS IS SHEILA BROWN I'M
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
I AM A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS ON THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION TEAM. AND
UPON UNIQUEMENT OF SB ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE IT SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY. THE LABOR CODE WAS
MODIFIED TO INCLUDE A
DISPUTABLE PRESUMPTION. THAT AN
EMPLOYEE'S ILLNESS OR DEATH AS
A RESULT OF THE NINETEEN-
ROSADO AND IN THE COURSE OF
EMPLOYMENT. THIS PRESUMPTION
PROVIDES FOR COMPATIBILITY
UNDER WORKER'S COMPENSATION IF
THE INDIVIDUAL IS A SPECIFIED
OF FRONTLINE EMPLOYEE. OR IF
THE PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT
EXPERIENCED AN OUTBREAK OF
COVER NINETEEN. IN ADDITION SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE SHORTEN THE
DETERMINATION TIMELINE FROM
NINETY DAYS TO THIRTY OR FORTY
FIVE DAYS. MEANING IF THE
EMPLOYER DOES NOT DISPUTE THE
CLAIM WITHIN THE REDUCE TIME
CONSTRAINTS THEN THE ILLNESS IS
PRESUMED TO BE WORK RELATED AND
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS
WILL BE ACCEPTED. AS A RESULT
CDCR REQUEST FIFTY ONE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND THESE FOR
TWENTY SEVEN LIMITED TERM
POSITION. IN ORDER TO RESPOND
TO INCREASING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SB ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE. THE BULK OF THE
REQUEST IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PAY OUT OF ACCEPTED CODE
NINETEEN CLAIMS. WHICH INCLUDES
MEDICAL COSTS SETTLEMENT COSTS
DISABILITY PAYMENTS CLAIMS
MANAGEMENT AND LITIGATION. IT
ALSO INCLUDES LIMITED TERM
POSITION TO HANDLE THE
INCREASED VOLUME OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS RELATED TO
COVER NINETEEN AND THAT THE
CERTAIN TIMELINE. THESE TASKS
REQUIRE SEVERAL COMPLEX AND
TECHNICAL STEPS AND CONTINUOUS
COORDINATION WITH THE EMPLOYEE
AND THE STATE CLAIMS
ADMINISTRATOR. AT THE TIME THE
P. C. P. WAS DEVELOPED IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS
YEAR'S DATA WAS ONLY AVAILABLE
THROUGH OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY.
AND CALIFORNIA WAS APPROACHING
A PROJECTED SURGE OF KOBE
NINETEEN INFECTIONS. AND A
VACCINE WAS ON THE HORIZON BUT
IT WAS NOT YET APPROVED NOR A
SCHEDULE RELEASED. SINCE THAT
TIME CALIFORNIA'S INFECTIOUS
NUMBERS HAVE DECLINED ALONG
WITH CITIES HERE. DUE TO THE
VOLATILITY OF CASE NUMBER SEEN
THROUGHOUT AND THEN MAKE.
CITIES ARE INCLUDED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE WHICH PLACES THE
FUNDING INTO ITS OWN LINE ITEM.
APPROPRIATION FOR TRANSPARENCY.
AND CAN ONLY BE SPENT FOR OVER
NINETEEN WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIMS. AND INCLUDES THE
STIPULATION THAT CDCR WILL
REVERT UNUSED FUNDING. TO THE
GENERAL FUND IT SHOULD COVER
NINETEEN CLAIMS COSTS REDUCE. I
HAVE SOME DATA POINTS FOR YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE AND JUST TO
GIVE YOU SOME PERSPECTIVE. SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE IS ACTIVE
THROUGH JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND THIS PERIOD
OF TIME COVERS- THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW SOME EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND SIXTY TWO TWENTY
WHICH COVERS FROM MARCH
NINETEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THROUGH JULY FIFTH. OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND NOW SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE GOES FROM THAT PERIOD
FORWARD. THERE'S ALSO AGAIN IT
IS NOT REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND WE HAVE HAD STAFF CLAIMS
ARE CURRENTLY APPROXIMATELY.
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
CDCR CLAIMS OUT OF A TOTAL OF
SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED. OR
SEVEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX STATEWIDE TOTAL
CLAIMS SO CITIES ARE HAS
APPROXIMATELY 45% OF THE
STATEWIDE OVERALL TOTAL. CLAIMS
FOR KOBE. OUR ALSO WE'RE
EXPECTING THAT THERE IS A GOT
AN APPROXIMATE TIMELINE OF
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF TO THREE
YEARS READ A HALF YEARS
APPROXIMATELY. FOUR COULD BE
CREATED TO BE SETTLED SO WE'VE
ASKED FOR BIDS VCP TO CONTINUE
THROUGH THE YEAR. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE FISCAL YEAR THAT AS
IN ORDER TO ALLOW ANY CLAIMS
RECEIVED UP UNTIL THE END OF.
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
BEFORE THE EXPIRATION OF THE
STATUTE. TO BE ABLE TO BE
SETTLED INDICATED- THROUGHOUT
THOSE FALLING TO YOUR CELL I
WILL NOW OPEN IT UP FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE. I
THINK YOU I APPRECIATE THE ANY
OF THE AND USE MONEY ADDS ABOUT
WORKERS COMPENSATION. SO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE UNUSED
MONIES WILL REFER REVERT BACK
TO BACK TO THE GENERAL FUND-
BUT IS THERE ANY WAY TO GET US.
SOME UPDATED NUMBERS YOU KNOW
DURING THE SPRING SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A MORE ACCURATE.
ASSESSING OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. ERIC SWANSON RECORD
THE OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES
BOB WE DID THE- WE DID TRY TO
DO THREE THINGS I THINK THAT
SHOULD A LOT OF BROUGHT UP TO.
SOME TRANSPARENCY TO THIS ISSUE
WE'RE NOT PLANNING ON UPDATING
THE NUMBERS FOR THE SPRING
PROCESS BUT- WE DO HAVE THE-
RIGHT TO GET ITS OWN ITEM SO
THERE COULD BE TRACKED BY
EVERYBODY INVOLVED. AND WE ALSO
HAVE LANGUAGE WHICH WOULD
REVERTED TO THE GENERAL FUND IF
IT GOES ON USE. FOR THE
SERVICES SO THIS IS ALL THE
INFORMATION WE'RE GOING TO GET
THIS TO BE. JUST TO BE CLEAR. I
THINK IN THAT TERRIBLE BECAUSE
THEY OF FUNDING ITSELF IS IN IS
IT A UP DATA. TRACKED BY
EVERYBODY WE CAN PROVIDE
REGULAR UPDATES AS FAR AS HOW
MUCH HAS BEEN SPENT BUT WE'RE
NOT PLANNING ON UPDATING THIS
PARTICULAR- PROPOSAL GIVEN THAT
MAY REVISE OKAY THANK YOU
LENITION MATTER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YES. HI I'D LIKE TO ADD
THAT ADDITIONAL SAID THAT THE
TIMELINE FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS CAN BE VERY
LONG AFTER THREE AND A HALF
YEARS ON AVERAGE SO EVEN IN THE
SPRING THERE'S PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT DATA TO
DO AN UPDATED PROJECTION FOR
WHAT THOSE COSTS WILL BE SO IT
WILL STILL. BE PREMATURE TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE. OKAY THANK
YOU- FOR THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS TRAINING PROPOSAL.
OFTEN THE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
GET A REFRESHER TRAINING ON THE
USE OF FORCE AND THE ESCALATION.
HELLO ALL OFFICERS GO THROUGH
TRAINING ANNUALLY ON USE OF
FORCE AND- DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES AS PART OF WHAT WE
CALL ANNUAL BLOCK TRAINING. AND
DO WE HAVE ANY WAY TO. HOW AN
SUCCESSFUL OR IMPACTFUL BE
STRAINING TO OUR. I AM
CURRENTLY I THINK WE WOULD LOOK
AT FOR STATISTICS- AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT ANY CHANGES IN
USE OF FORCE POLICY HAVE REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF USE OF FORCE AND
TO INSTANCES- BUT AGAIN THAT'S
NOT AND DATA HAVE AVAILABLE TO
YOU TODAY. SO WHEN FIX AIMS
WILL HAVE A BETTER IDEA OKAY
THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. I'M SURE THIS
IS YES I HAVE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
AVAIL OKAY WE DID HAVE THAT-
COMMENTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
THE CORRECTIONAL STAFF TRAINING
AND JOB SHADOWING PROPOSAL
WHICH WE DID NOT RAISE CONCERNS
ON THE OTHER TWO PROPOSALS AS
PART OF THIS ITEM BEEN. AT SO
MOVING ON TO OUR COMMENTS ON
THAT TRAINING PROPOSAL A
STRUCTURE THEM AROUND EACH OF
THE SEPARATE COMPONENTS AND
THEN ONE PROVIDE ONE OVER
ARCHING COMMENT SO FIRST ON THE
RESOURCES REQUESTED FOR THE
COMMISSION ON CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING OR SEATPOST. WE THINK
THAT THE RESOURCES WOULD BETTER
POSITION SUPPOSED TO FILL ITS
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES AND SO WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THEM
HOWEVER WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THE PROPOSAL DOESN'T FACILITATE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
THAT'S BECAUSE- WHILE THE
PROPOSAL WHICH PROVIDES DEPOTS
WITH FUNDING TO BETTER MONITOR
STAFF TRAINING AND PERFORMANCE.
IT DOESN'T PLAN TO ACT IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE A PLAN TO KEEP
THE LEGISLATURE INFORMED OF
THESE FINDINGS WE THINK THAT
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE HEARD IN
ISSUE ONE TODAY- TO THE EXTENT
THAT GAVE RECENT OUT THERE THE
REPEATED ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT COULD BE TIED TO
TRAINING DEFICIENCIES- SO WE
RECOMMEND PASSING TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION REQUIRING SUPPOSED
TO REPORT ANNUALLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE BEGINNING JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ON DATA
RELEVANT TO TRAINING OUTCOMES
AND CONCLUSIONS BECAUSE- DRAWS
FROM THE DATA AND ANY PLANS IT
HAS TO ADDRESS. THE CONCERNS.
ARE CHALLENGES THAT IDENTIFIES.
SECOND I WE RECOMMEND. FUND FOR
THE NEW. FACILITY FOR HIM ON.
FOR CORRECTION OFFICERS GIVEN
THAT IT APPEARS THAT WORTHWHILE
TO INSURING CORRECTIONAL
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE
SUFFICIENTLY. PREPARED TO BEGIN
WORKING. THIRD WE THINK THAT
THE IDEA OF THE JOB SHADOWING
PROGRAM SIMILARLY SEEMS
WORTHWHILE BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THAT TWO OF THE
RESOURCE AS REQUESTED TO
SUPPORT IT- SO FIRST THE THIRTY
THREE SERGEANT POSITIONS
REQUESTED. BY THE PROGRAM
SEVENTEEN OF THOSE POSITIONS
ARE DRIVEN BY WORKLOAD THAT'S
NEW AND ASSOCIATED WITH THE JOB
SHADOWING PROGRAM. HOWEVER THE
REMAINING SIXTEEN POSITIONS ARE
INTENDED TO RELIEVE EXISTING
STAFF OF CERTAIN TASKS SUCH AS
MAINTAINING FITNESS EQUIPMENT
TESTING EQUIPMENT SO THAT THE
OTHER- EXISTING STAFF ARE SO
THAT THOSE EXISTING BACK
INSTEAD FOCUS ON OTHER
ACTIVITIES. LIKE SCHEDULING
STAFF FOR THEIR ANNUAL
TRAININGS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
REPORTS ARE NOT GETTING DONE IN
A TIMELY MANNER BUT THE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE INFORMATION ON
THE EXTENT THAT THOSE TASKS
AREN'T. EVEN BEING- COMPLETED
IN A TIMELY MANNER- IN OTHER
WORDS- THE DEPARTMENT HAD AT
PROVIDED DETAILED ANALYSIS ON-
CURRENT WORKLOAD AND THE NUMBER
OF POSITIONS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE IN A
TIMELY MANNER. SO WE RECOMMEND
AT REJECTING SIXTEEN POSITIONS
THAT AREN'T TIED DIRECTLY TO
THE NEW JOB TRAINING PROGRAM
WHICH WOULD REDUCE THE FUNDING
NEEDED BY TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION ANNUALLY. AND THE
SECOND RESOURCE THAT- WE HAVE
CONCERNED WITH THAT'S REQUESTED
FOR THE NEW JOB SHATTERING
PROGRAM IS THATYOU SIX POINT
TWO MILLION TO PAY NEW OFFICERS
WHILE THEY'RE DOING THE JOB
SHADOWING- AND THE REASON WE
ARE CONCERNED WITH THAT IT'S
SIMPLY THAT THE FUNDING AMOUNT
AS SOON. ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NEW OFFICERS
PER YEAR BUT CDC ARE A SINCE
REVISED THAT ESTIMATE TWO ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX NEW OFFICERS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. SO WHAT WE RECOMMEND
REDUCING THE FUNDING
ACCORDINGLY- WHICH WOULD BE BY
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION. AND
FOR- OVER ARCHING COMMENT IS
THAT PRISON CLOSURES WILL
REDUCE FUTURE NEED FOR
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WHEN PRISONS ARE
CLOSE OFFICERS AT THOSE
PRESENTS CAN. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE ELSEWHERE
IN THE STATE TO FILL VACANCIES
AT THE REMAINING PRESENTS.
REDUCING THE NEED FOR NEW
OFFICERS- TO BE PRODUCED. BY
THE ACADEMY. SO WHILE
HISTORICALLY THAT THE NEED FOR
DOCTORS HAVE BEEN FAIRLY
CONSISTENT FROM YEAR TO YEAR-
MEANING AND AS A RESULT CDCR
BUDGET. ISN'T ADJUSTED ANNUALLY
TO ACCOUNT FOR CHANGES IN THE
NUMBER OF OFFICERS NEW OFFICERS
AT NEEDS TO PRODUCE- HOWEVER.
GIVEN PRISON CLOSURES ON THE
HORIZON- CTC ARTS. BASED BUDGET
FOR THE PROPER TRAINING AS WELL
AS THE PERFECT PROPOSALS BEFORE
YOU TODAY- ADVOCATES OFFICER
TRAINING- PROGRAM. COULD BECOME
EXCESSIVE SO WE RECOMMEND
PASSING BUDGET TRAILER
LEGISLATION REQUIRING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROPOSE.
ADJUSTMENTS THE CITY'S AIRSPACE
BUDGET FOR TRAINING NEW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS- THIS WOULD BE
SIMILAR TO HOW OTHER AREAS OF
CITIES YEAR'S BUDGET ARE
CURRENTLY. ADJUSTED ANNUALLY.
BASED ON VARIOUS FACTORS LIKE.
THE NUMBER OF INMATES ARE
PAROLEES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE THREE TO FIND SEVENTY TO
ADD LIVE NATION UNDER DEPART OF
FAINTING THANK YOU MATT AND-
OUT WE DO NOT RELATED TO THE
RIVER ON THE OUT WE DO NOT IT'S
NECESSARY. TO PUT IT INTO
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BUT WE
RESPECT THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
INFORMATION AND WERE OPEN TO
DISCUSSING IDEAS REGARDING
USEFUL REPORTING METRICS WE
WOULD WANT TO EVALUATE WHAT
REPORTING THAT DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY DOES AS WELL AS ANY
POTENTIAL FISCAL IMPACTS OF
PROPOSED REPORTING ALTERNATELY
CCAR'S COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESS
OF IMPLEMENTING THEIR
ADDITIONAL TRADING RESOURCES-
AND ALSO IN RESPONSE TO THE
SERGEANTS FOR THE JOB
SHATTERING. IT WE BELIEVE IT'S
CRITICAL TO HAVE A SERGEANT AT
EACH INSTITUTION DEDICATED TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROGRAM INSTITUTIONS HAVE
DIFFERENT MISSIONS DIFFERENTLY
OUT INMATE POPULATIONS AND
OTHER UNIQUE ATTRIBUTES AND
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THAT THE
STAFF WHO OVERSEE THE JOB
SHADOWING PROGRAM ARE WELL
VERSED IN THE SPECIFICS OF
THEIR INSTITUTION. THAT WAY THE
CRIMINAL OFFICERS CAN RECEIVE
SITE SPECIFIC TRAINING
ADDITIONALLY THE SERGEANTS
SERGEANTS WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR WORKING WITH THE CURRENT
POSTED STAFF WHO WILL BE
ACTUALLY DOING THEIR JOB
SHADOWING AT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
INFORMATIVE AFFECTED MAXIMIZES
THE.NEW OFFICERS LEARNING
EXPERIENCE. APOSTLES THAT
CONTINUED I. TO ENSURE THE IT'S
IN PLACE ARE CARP TRAINED FROM
DEFEAT IT WILL INCREASE ACCOUNT.
BY MAKING. THE NEW OXFORD.
AFTER MEETING WITH. AND IN OUR
TO THE AREA ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
ACADEMY OUT WE DON'T BELIEVE IT
WE BELIEVE IT'S PREMATURE TO
CONSIDER THIS TYPE OF AN
ADJUSTMENT THERE'S STILL
NUMEROUS UNKNOWNS IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE WHICH MAKE
IT DIFFICULT TO ESTIMATE
OFFICER NEEDED LONG TERM FUTURE
ATTRITION RATE IS BASED ON A
NUMBER OF FACTORS INCLUDING THE
EFFECTS OF COCAINE SALARY AND
BENEFIT COMPENSATION AND THE
EFFECTS OF PRESIDENT BUSH OR
EVEN IF THERE IS REDUCING IT
TEMPORARILY. THERE WILL BE
CONTINUED RETIREMENTS WHICH
WOULD NECESSITATE OFFICERS ARE
WILLING WE BELIEVE IT ARE STILL
PREMATURE TO IT SURE DOES THAT
THIS ISSUE ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONSIDER
CONSOLIDATION. WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. OKAY WE
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND OPEN
IT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE IS
IMPATIENTLY WAITING. WE'RE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENTS BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT I IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE THE AGENDA AND SHOULD
BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
STREAMING THE HEARING. JUST IN
CASE THE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS
WELL YOU CAN SUBMIT THAT BUDGET
SUB FIVE AT ASM. THAT CA DOT
GOV AND IT'S ALSO LISTED ON THE
AGENDA. DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHO
WISH TO SPEAK PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND. THERE IS NO ONE IN THE
ROOM. THE OPERATORS PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT EACH PERSON HAS A FEW
ONE MINUTE BY THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL VIA THE PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER
AND WHEN YOU'RE LINE NUMBERS
CALLED PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THE RECORD. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU DO HAVE A COMMENT FOR
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS. TIME.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO COMMENTS
IN Q. HERNANGOMEZ AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GIVE IT A MOMENT. ARE THERE
STILL LOCAL NO ONE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME CASEY THAT THERE'S NO
COMMENTS MAKE HERE WILL THANK
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S HEARING WILL ENSURE FOR
TODAY THANK YOU.